stay calm all disruptions are
intentional yeah let's keep going so
we're now at part six of the stream
coincidentally Friday the 13th part six
is the best of all the Jason Voorhees
movies Jason lives that's a fact it's
not actually a fact but it's a fact in
my opinion this music is just so good
the specifically liked this song for
this level was one of my favorite video
game things it's just like it takes me
back to childhood innocence and getting
so angry that I throw my controller
towards the TV yep actually an
interesting thing about all those old
consoles when they were cartridge based
is that they were actually also
synthesizers so like the music you hear
is programmed and and the console
reproduces it as a synthesizer it's not
like pre-recorded and just playing a
track it's pretty crazy
oh yeah this part is really frustrating
but the I think they cut man weapon is
the way to go there oh yeah this part is
pretty notorious and another nice thing
about the tablet version is they kind of
let you jump through the bottom to get
on till up see though I think if you
hold the jug yeah if you hold the jump
button down he goes up even higher
[Music]
speaking of synthesizers that's when I
play in the end yes Diana in addition to
singing all the scenes are back now have
you experienced disruption that's on you
that's nothing to do with us and I'm
sorry these things happen that's all
life goes now we're not going anywhere
anytime soon
[Music]
it's 6:00 a.m. I have to go to bed see
all letters have fun everyone thank you
spectroscopy you have frontier have a
good night's sleep
pleasant dreams logic for actually a lot
of these original nintendo games have
been released on the Google Play Store
and that's where we got them from just
perfect for me and also dangerous for
the amount of time that I spent on it so
you guys are watching the team cocoa
Google Play 24-hour mobile marathon I'm
John Dannic I'm Diana we work a team
cocoa digital and we're playing mega man
into the wee hours of the morning yeah
he wants us to see to see the end of the
game I we could maybe get through all
the individual levels but I think
Wiley's castle would be particularly
difficult katsumi Kison are we touring
New York City any time soon we've mostly
been touring the Greater downtown Los
Angeles area with some tour stops in
Santa Monica that's the extent that we
played thus far what's our EP comes out
the others yeah
[Music]
and music he how do you like the wood
man from Mega Man 2 if I recall the boss
is very difficult and what's the weapon
do I can't think off the top of my head
of what his weapon does burn diesel I'm
glad that you're awake and watching us
now
that's exciting a little refresh to make
sure that we're up on all the chats and
everything got our tech crew on the job
O'Malley yeah everybody chasing they're
recording you know him from his cameos
finally behind the camera on many a
Conan sketch in Team Coco digital
production which one it is this is the
elect men
[Music]
all right so I know we want to get to
the left so we go to the left and then
wait on that second one wait there you
make it look so easy I have a lot of
time on my hands and I played this game
actually pretty recently there's a
reason I asked for it
oh no I want to go to the other side you
know I must have played it back recently
[Music]
so you just got a puddle a guitar pedal
that
sounds like this music right yeah one of
my friends from back in Pennsylvania
runs a company a new upstart company RPS
effects and he's building guitar and
bass effects pedals and he's very good
at it and one pedal I have kind of makes
my guitar sound like an 8-bit
synthesizer - really Holly can - sadly
gone I'm sorry to report thank when went
alone in Italy be available sometime in
April April yeah that that's going to be
a good that's awesome hello to you as
well what other areas we have watching
the show right now where you guys from
chat where are you from
Danna - I know but I'm from southwestern
Pennsylvania which explains why I'm a
die-hard Steelers fan I'm told that I
have an accent yeah I can when when
necessary I can really crank up the
Pittsburgh actually it sounds a little
something like oh my god you kids
wouldn't believe how late it is
we're playing Google Play Store games
play Mega Man original Mega Man
I love the soundtrack but I wish we had
a little more daunting iris up in here
that's that is what a lot of people in
Pittsburgh sound like
yeah I'm from the South I'm from North
Carolina I don't really hear much south
going I mean I never had a strong accent
can you like summon it back yeah I would
cuz when I used to live there
I didn't notice like strong like I don't
have a strong accent but they like do
that and then and then then I'm moved to
New York and like I felt weird having
this like very slight yeah it's like the
slight thing that people get really
weirded out by it's not out of like if
you're full-blown southern people are
like okay you're from the south it's
when you have like a tiny bit you're
like why are you talking slightly
bizarrely see we've got a lot of Russia
watching Hong Kong hello hello pants
Annette oh man I see you're from the
area is it it's 600 yeah it's 3:00 a.m.
here so it's 6 a.m. cue persona wake up
in Pittsburgh Vermont Slovakia I'm part
Slovakian that's exciting don't look
like I'll take that when we first all
right let's see somebody type Jeff
Goldblum in all caps and oh yeah we got
a few times I'd actually picture with
you yeah took the picture yeah
you guys Jeff you and Jeff gold when we
were like long-lost father and son yeah
exact same height
yeah and we were actually wearing
similar clothes which really made it
like bizarre
that's funny if you're in the Los
Angeles area you should look up Jeff
Goldblum because he does a lot of live
jazz performances and it's it's a good
time blow from Portugal Taiwan China
lanta I befriended in Atlanta Portugal
yeah then lotta places was awesome yeah
some you should probably probably have
like 8 a.m. class where you guys John
there we go
you gotta hear Blair back on the gutter
back in the podcast my not a top third
of your head yeah there we go
alright how's it going lamb plants the
mega man I can't get up this ladder
right man
I hate mega man mega man is ridiculously
hard for no reason I like that you hate
mega man but we're playing it yeah got a
brand-new shirt on boxing gloves yeah
look at these comedic Lisa over sized
boxing gloves everybody
punch punch quest have you played that
no that's a good time waster because
it's simple its action packs really good
I don't believe in violence damn it I
don't believe that for a second all
right
based on how Koda treats you I think you
would only Mallen I didn't flake on you
either go to sleep drooling what time
did you wake up Tuesday morning that's a
great question I don't remember I don't
remember anything other than right now
in this pizza which is delicious
I'm really tired what's your season less
you guys Jim Josh was great Christmas
what a guy I been working for the show
for 16 years I have so many jackets and
bags all the swag you have average shoes
and so much swag and I give it all to my
mom so my mom wears for our 10th
anniversary and Conan is not watching
he's asleep right now I mean he'll be
checking in he'll be awake in about 20
minutes to check in with us but for our
10th anniversary
10th anniversary for late-night right
that's a big deal yes a big deal a show
makes it to 10 years that's a big deal
like oh my god like how many shows make
it I think friends only went to nine
seasons you know so it gives us this
awesome jacket it's the coolest Jackie
you've ever seen it's like a Letterman's
jacket you know like a varsity jacket
that's like leather and it's beautiful
and you turn it around
and it has the biggest ugliest looking
patch that has ever been made by human
hands in the back it's like this big
it's a patch but it's like a trapezoid
it's like a weird it's like if the
Flintstones all got together and decided
to I don't know do drugs and then they
tried to create what they thought would
be a stone-age television and then right
late night it's insane and my mom loves
it and she wears it almost every day and
gets compliments on it every day back in
Michigan I want to say I think the only
person I've ever seen wear that in the
current day is la Bamba yeah yeah I see
he was around all the time
Ritchie is notorious for wearing all of
our all of the late night and and densho
and ancona and swag He pours it proudly
and rightly so Obama yeah this is for
you pal yeah my brother and in losing
weight he lost a lot of weight he always
runs around a lot and I don't know if
he's being chased or if it's for health
reasons yeah we all have our demons
bears you don't be sad you're here be
happy acidic fish what's going on we
love you there you go hey Caleb Campbell
hey you guys wanna play a game called
space team air played space - yeah you
I have no idea what it is what's wrong
yeah it's exciting
why are you don't get little Mon why
spend all my time playing Mega Man and
games it came out like 1988 what Mega
Man is like what was the guy what's the
guy wily is that the head guy dr. Wilde
I know while he creates a a guy with one
hand and one gun for dr. light okay ask
you that's gonna be learn your Mega Man
three hours of megaman tune into our
megaman only stream with john Danny no
not great okay okay great he's all out
there would love it rates a strong word
all right hold on I'm gonna I feel like
blade bite by nature that probably not a
huge static up head hmm I'm sorry what
was that did you become dead oh god no
the plan for clueless gamer I only
played a bike before it was done so I've
actually played the full game okay why I
beat it okay you need to be a jerk I
mean I've been waiting all day yeah I
did say earlier before you got here so
that's number two Oh Lord
you know it's it's the little victories
you have to hold on oh my god like even
Diana's about to fall is she so bored by
your bragging it happens okay so we're
gonna play a little game called space TV
I can't stand this music anymore I'm
gonna murder it is pleasing now when
it's like two bars or it is a very short
amount yeah okay so here we go
now if you guys what's happening is this
like you you can't if you seemed it was
an awesome spike jump that I missed did
you jump over some spikes Tanika Danna
I played flawlessly and I never done the
truth comes out the truth it is 3:15
a.m. for us we're going strong
how strong so strong like deliriously
strong delivery work we're past like the
low point and we've got so low that
we're back that's right that's how these
things work that's right alright so
we're gonna play if I can get it loaded
up on this machine which it might not be
it should because it's amazing all right
I got a download on here uh but I'm just
gonna go to the Google Play Store and
download it so kids don't worry about it
yeah well now what did I miss when I was
asleep
what did i I we pass madness got chat
what did I miss
what did I miss everybody Jack the dog
was here and I think really stole the
rules and ghost Crash Bandicoot I eject
the dog was here that's we had an animal
in here that's great like to our lesson
on cue cards from learn the value of the
cue card versus the teleprompter and
what is the value and in a nutshell well
is the value of mobility mobility get
and they like played pars and like the
characters are all like did you start it
was Michael all right so okay here's the
game guys guys this game is about
teamwork as the name space team might
imply it's about friendship well you're
gonna stab us in the back of the first
pump no no no this is a game we work
together there's no stabbing works if I
stab you in the back I'm stabbing myself
in the back I thought you would do that
though there's no I in team but there is
a me and team and also there is meet in
team a lot of you know it's basically
the word meat but rearranged I don't
know that means but oh wait so what
we're gonna do is yeah so we're gonna do
is I see Internet that's good you want
to turn it down internet connection mode
is that what your honor yes
alright so just go over to play there
you can bring these guys to see if you
can bring now we're not gonna be able to
you know - I'll I'll change it to you
Dan ik so you can this is still okay if
you know what you're doing you should
man the oh I don't know what I'm doing
oh no never I never know
that's a mistake that's gonna do that's
huh all right hold on a second okay
space team Admirals Club all right so
we're gonna try something we haven't
tried before yet on this stream which is
oh you know what
okay great here we go oh the music on
this game is really good yeah that's
right you guys tell them about your band
[Music]
that's a new followers there one more
Jay Jay this game is called space team
EP coming out what's the name of your EP
is it color
her name's Shang Dynasty
you know like that that's pretty good
it's pretty good yeah all right so this
is so I'm on the right I'm right here
this is me this wait this this oh my god
this is me right here and I think this
is you Diana you're there why don't you
take this one you take it yeah yeah
don't want to see oh okay okay I screwed
yeah all right all right we're not gonna
see we're not gonna see Danis you play
introduces chaos at all things oh I see
all right so they want you to give up
you know never have so ladies you tablet
but I guess no problem no gentleman in
the back there let's get let's cut to
camera two real quick yeah let's see
what's going on back here yeah that's
right the people keeping us alive it's
right let's shine the light yeah
you got Silicon Valley back there now I
keep yelling at O'Malley to take a nap
he won't do it
yeah I support that O'Malley take a nap
everybody in the chat tell Jason I'm
about to take a nap this guy needs to go
to sleep the real team exactly grizzly
Grill Ali taken that by [ __ ] smell
thank you for watching
Wow I wish we could make the facebook
chat smaller untitled it's very meta so
casually confusing so I'm gonna play
space team now all of us here the great
thing about here's here's now with space
team here's the deal
oh I'm gonna set the scene for you guys
okay we're honest spaceship okay out in
space that makes sense we're a team
fallin in space you lost me at cult
space team okay and we need to work
together so we're gonna have you well
you're gonna see on your your tablet on
your screen is a control panel okay and
it's gonna have weird stuff on it now we
all have different things okay you might
have a flim-flam generator you might
have a Ghibli Jolly Gible job and I
might have a thing of a Bob now it's
gonna tell there's gonna be instructions
that are going to come up and we have to
do those things so it says turn the
jumble Javas to three I might get that
instruction but I have to tell you hey
you got to turn your Gible Javas to
three and you have to do it okay that
makes sense
all right so it's about communication
it's about friendship it's about
teamwork Chang you're ready teamwork dad
and daddy all right let's get in here
yes let's get in here Shang Dynasty on
three one two three cheering Dynasty all
right let's do it
oh we gots a star-filled in the middle
here guys this is gonna be great yeah
we're playing space teams Madeline Sims
the guy with the white hair name that's
me my name is Erin Blair people call me
Blake or people call me dork or people
call me hey how did you get in here
please leave okay here we go all right
everybody hold down there their thing
here another good EP name suggestion -
Chang
everybody hold down there hold down I'm
shooting something here we go space
[Music]
teams to go to sleep he needs to go to
sleep this he's getting crazy who's
getting crazy it's happening oh yeah I
know the tablet doesn't matter I'm on
this this couldn't literally could
nothing matters more than this here we
go pay attention space team all right go
to sleep Jason says big smokes thank you
big smokes I want to start a hashtag go
to sleep Jason stay awake creeper don't
stay awake I support the stay awake
movement here we go okay prepare to
receive it stretches here we go
everybody here we go
that's a communication or here we go
activate flash nexus awesome set hydro
alarm two one activate room chain
activated activate flash Nexus no enable
phase lens phase lens enabled stir ecto
bolt oh oh that's me sorry activate
deactivate rim datameer dynamo
deactivate rim chain deactivated set
hydro alarm to zero
no engage micro pivot oh that's me
enable helio vents activated nice
activate flash Nexus disable phase lens
the activate mirror dynamo deactivated
entertained dignitaries dignitaries to
be danced oh you know what I was about
to - I'm not like a delay or something
all right oh god this is gonna be hard
yeah ignite triple cord okay triple cord
ignited deactivated rim chain
I said Hydra line three enabled enable
try cloud try clawed a naval drain flip
cycle oh my god the fireball is gaining
guys I'm nervous deactivated did we do
it space teen inject super thruster wait
no sorry my fees lens is almost disabled
Helio vents activate rip change Jesus
it's activated alright disengage
unstable just disengage macro pivot
drain flip cycle Oh disengage mcafee
disabled behind hyperspace yes we did it
we did it you're ahead of us yes that's
nice not like how we do you need to
establish a system but we developed one
and stuff that's true you're right
you're right we're pretty good at space
teaming I think yeah is what that is
this is a disaster intense hacking the
fortune nice job nice job
good night thank you for sitting with us
thanks for having the Cheers
[ __ ] right you that was all that was
sector one I'm worried because Diana is
like living ahead of us yeah this is
kind of is this what happens when you're
in hyperspace like people age at
different times vana you're aging faster
than us I think clearly yeah this is
like no I mean clearly for me this is
like interstellar I kind of feel like
that moment where Matthew McConaughey
not to spoil things
he watches like all these messages and
he's weeping and it's horrifying
so that's basically Spacey
I'm gonna age faster than you guys I'm
gonna then come
Oh God over that's so much harder okay
no wait
are we all listen okay okay I plunger it
just says hyperspace for me am I on my
own explain myself
oh no he's not space teen and I haven't
got one plunger I think we gotta quit
out of space team and come back to it
what do you guys think yeah that's right
those of you in the front of the ship
are experiencing different time than
those in the back of the ship that's
true again Gers time dilation they call
it all right we got to get out of space
team and come back to it here all right
let's restart our space team all right
here we go
no we are we all on here's a question
all right so rescan you restart your
space team Danny all right are you on
internet connection mode you are okay we
all are okay everybody turn our thing oh
[Music]
yeah I should have known something was
up at the beginning when we wouldn't
shoot our guns all at the same time up
there wild space boys sure we are pretty
wild space boys and girls that's right
inclusion quad plunger I guess it does
quite plunge for toilets at once that's
my question is why are four toilets so
close together with no obstruction
between them that's exactly Mike it's
like that's like a high school bathroom
build in those I think that toilet
arrangement would be basically all
people pooping looking out Oh back to
back back to back to back
okay so it's kind of like a four-leaf
clover of toilet if you're looking down
on it you could do that or you can have
them in a wine because then but then you
need a plunger that's like like real
like a big like this like a big like
that could be easier to manufacture a
job but harder to use part definitely
Diana what's your opinion on this
four-way plunger situation
the design of the spaceship okay I love
where you go yes go on yeah it's where
the bathroom is and where the sewage
like where the pipes are that's choose
where the sewage line is probably be on
the side yeah that's true
here my question though here's my
question why can't you just basically
shoot all that stuff out into space why
do you even need guys junk if there's
any yeah but you're out your space with
it what if you're on space all right you
got a can't come back it's hurtling
through space towards Earth it becomes
so dense that it makes it through the
atmosphere and then crashes like into a
Walmart I think that's not the
transformer movie started I have it
seems plausible those are like real
science documentaries basically
restarting I'm shooting a gun my
favorite thing is I think I think other
people are trying to get in and play
with us are other people trying to play
with us because it's not gonna work you
can't play with us because see there's
some kind of delay going on here then
yeah that's not gonna this isn't gonna
work
get out of space too you don't play
space t think the password up on the
screen and we're screaming we can't
delay there's no margin for error in
space Diana there's no margin for error
I don't know Simon Lebon of Duran Duran
does still have it
I agree I haven't seen Simon Simon Lebon
in a while I'm gonna give him the
benefit of the doubt but it's possible
he doesn't have it
no I've had a lot of pizza actually I
never eat pizza so I'm like high on
pizza you gotta just do one of these
things and then you definitely not in
the game changing the password to
something different
wink wink there you go there's the
password you just heard of this wink
wink yes they heard you say that all
right the smarted you chat yet again
waiting for our space team signals I'm
still floating around in space Oh Here I
am
the portal is opening all right now we
can shoot a gun in the password is
password ooh
cable got reference all right here we go
no wait I'm not shooting my gosh darn
gun guys don't give up on me okay this
is what a team is all about never leave
a space team or behind so far I've used
space team is both a verb and a noun and
we're gonna play space team Lisa now
I've used it as an adverb all right
space team it is if you can make it a
gerund I'll be doubly impressed the
passer is nine says pick any pocket
dang it wink wink Jason yeah nice try
now you know I like this character
better and it's basically signs you
random characters and I like this dude
better and I secretly wish I had a tail
cuz tails are cool you know you guys
wish you had a tail yeah I mean I'd have
to buy all the pants yeah you know or
just cut holes in my pants I tend to
sleep on my back and I feel like that
would be a problem oh yeah for sure yeah
but here's what here's the thing now I
don't want to get gross on this dream I
don't want to bring the stream down drag
it down to my level but you're about to
yeah if let's say we had tails would it
count is more of an arm appendage or
something else that you wouldn't be able
to see what we'd have to wear something
over our tails a tail cover Diana what's
your opinion on this I think would be
like our hair okay oh no see I was
talking about like a prehensile monkey
tail oh you're thinking like like a nub
no no what like no oh my god thank god
I've already gone to sleep otherwise I'd
be having nub nightmares I was asleep
no I'm talking about it no we're sorry
Oh No okay turned on fire macro loom
centaur Kona full power I said it to
full power turn on dark so excite soo
doo doo bah bobbin explosion contain
turn on echo vector turn off dark sail
[Music]
turn off dark cell okay
excite sudo bobbin space team this is
how your space team oh man this is just
like that Christopher Nolan movie what
is it don't know interstellar sorry just
like interstellar guys many humans are
born with tails but hospitals are told
to track to track it in the US it
instantly gets abandoned because their
rates are used I does a long comment
about tails
one-third of babies have nubs I think
that's what set sparkle counter to to
engage ion circuit
oh there's the thing I don't know what
it does anyone have an eye on sir I am
engaging this thing
oh it's wrong turn on eros scale to set
shift pivot scissor to - oh my god okay
it's at the to put away thingamajig good
away I don't know the crease smart
counter to one okay off set shift pivot
scissor - full power
okay full power sets smart counter to
zero I have a number three nipples I
have neither turn on whiteboard house
what's that wrench vortex turn on turned
on turn off phase wheel odd sorry turn
off base wheel poly leaver engaged turn
on mirrored clutch fill emergency probe
we did we did oh we didn't see probe
Diana you are definitely on this is time
dilation in action guys this is time
this is Einsteins theory of
something-or-other relativity or
something
I don't why we first of all she's not
rod just said yes and I love your
positivity you know I get no she's not
rocks talking about but I like the word
yes hyperspace please spore luck says
until you you're awake for 48 hours you
haven't lived have you ever been awake
for 48 hours I've been awake for 31
hours I was awake for 30 we did a oh god
oh no see look this is ridiculous
I'm behind you guys to make this on a
cake no I can't space teams I'm back oh
no okay what is it
sonic age sonic age activated engage
flush nozzle I did a bubble fill engaged
meteor engage flat flush nozzle you guys
it's a game damnit grandmas
wine Oh moon boxes I'm Brian I ground
the moon box enable univ o derp I've got
a lot of things happening over here man
my pain deactivate the Tzadik a sonic a
deactivated meteor hub engaged ship
it'll enable brush echo booster set
emergency floated to you no motor
enabled enable rim cloud enabled fill
ball bowl okay it's filled set grip
flush to to disable shift pedal just
filled the sheep disengage question ops
watch nozzle disengaged set radio p21
enable rim cloud renewal poke subdermal
drunk evil the rim cloud that's not the
piece it's enabled okay yes it's a
verbal drum who's got the cellphone no
guys I'm left behind I'm fine
who's got the unbind this subdermal
jumbo Oh Iowa hyperspace okay alright
this is definitely a problem we gotta
figure this out this is a fun game this
is we're getting we're getting space
teamed up the wazoo if you catch my
meaning
yeah you know I'm getting real space
team or space steamed right that's what
I would do with my veggies I would space
steam them you guys ever okay maybe
that's too much
all right oh we got a labeling
malfunction happening this is awesome
for 3:37 a.m. you know it is okay I'm
right ready
activated engage power sister engage
disengage power sister disengage super
pod engaged man
disengage super pod it still says on my
thing that pillow exciters to everybody
that's right set in fro pod em fro safe
into five set the five deactivated that
premium shackle to zero I feel like I'm
on a different ship than you guys turn
on the mechanical connectors it's on oh
that's me I got disengaged
alright engaged okay set super socket to
one okay got that
it's Jimmy engage turn off mechanical
connector anyone also mine isn't going
down a sword switch to one okay set the
one I'm just my spines lists are enabled
hydro turn off synth box activated oh no
someone's blowing up over here oh no
somebody blew up I think we did it
uh-oh somebody's floating in space and
they got credits but I'm still alive
somehow turn our synth box anyone the
best part about
living in the past is oh wait no what
are they what did you what do we get the
accomplishments number players three
sectors reach for seventy instructions
completed that seems good all right
there we go now I'm still alive
so maybe did you guys just inject your
ship or something cuz I'm still and by
the way my stuff isn't is it going down
so I think I live forever yeah I'm
basically in crisis I'm like cryo sleep
I had the bladder of a toddler so I'll
be right back all right
bladder Matala is a weird way to say you
have to go to the bathroom alright but
he has to go should we just play the two
of us now that we lost the dead weight
yeah all right here all right we're
gonna we're gonna play a little but
don't don't put us up yet on the thing
so we can so no one knows our password
he tries to get into our game cuz I know
you want to play with us but you can't
I'm sorry because it did delay it's not
gonna work
please EBT or Wi-Fi we could yeah let's
try you see what you know let's try
using the old Wi-Fi
let's try this open it up we're gonna
try Wi-Fi connection mode
oh my god you can i zoom in you can zoom
in with like you're just doing that back
there see how close you can get to our
faces put your head right next my head
can you get it can you get it tight get
in tight I could feel can you feel the
lice jumping from my head to your head
get in there get in there tight get it
right in where our heads are touching
right in there right in right it closer
closer closer enhance enhance enhance
you can see the lice going from one hair
enhance oh my god all right stop
enhancing I don't want to see our
molecules then there's the earth it's
beautiful alright that's pretty great in
hands are dirty pores people screaming
that's right nice Sheen says Kai strand
to scoff yes dying a punch alright just
give me a little punch they're doing it
dad is not one for physical violence oh
look at that point back there you guys
are point give yourselves the old camera
to treatment good let's see what
happened ah there we go there we go
there's Jason O'Malley in the corner he
should go to sleep I'm gonna tell him to
go to sleep
wait we're back we're back all right
we're gonna play oh we're gonna go on
Wi-Fi connection mode Dannic that's our
that seems like a better bet yeah I
think that that's a new plan that's a
new first you use that one then we'll
we'll switch on camera wait what's
happening we Dana that's just some cool
pants Egon
yeah what the hell is today my boss you
know I wish yes nappy nap all right we
on are we honest your cat says punch the
nerd but I think you have to narrow that
down yeah you got someone's gonna be
punching ourselves yeah punching
ourselves you know just pineapple belong
on pizza I say yes
anything belongs on pizza including
anchovies
I think that's an abomination you know
what I made a pizza that had other
little pizzas on it but it was amazing
pizza inception Pizza inception I'm a
dying in the crying's as Madeline Sims
well you know what oh there we go Pizza
sucks and you all suck Jason that's not
true that I don't want to troll the deal
choice this isn't working let's try a
Bluetooth everybody we're gonna try
blinky welcome to the 24-hour mobile
marathon sponsored by google play where
we spend three hours just try to connect
here we go I'm gonna host oh that was a
yeah I think oh my god O'Malley's like
slamming doors yeah it's crazy the rage
is starting
how many called Bruce if he had O'Malley
don't lie to me cuz I'll know how many
days go bro three that's three Cobras
dangerous business
Alex hunter agrees that a pineapple
doesn't believe what it's country we
said that it does belong there refer
away with ham or bacon well then you
know what but here's the thing people
say people say oh how those belong on
pizza but there's what about what's your
opinion out on the dessert pizza but
you're painting a dessert pizza this is
interesting this is an interesting
situation I'm gonna go this is not what
it's gonna be
this is that no this is nothing I know I
did the wrong thing
yeah I'm pretty sure you I think we're
gonna have to go to Internet mode get it
do it hey hey or is Dow how's it going
good to see everyone is yelling I love
how we're not supposed to address
negative comments but somebody said taco
pizza is gross I don't consider it nice
I don't consider taco pizza a negative
comments frankly I think that's you say
that it's gross it's I'm gonna hook us
up all right you explain with taco Pete
taco pizza is served in many public
schools across the United States of
America it is in an octagonal shape
there's a neon orange cheese substance
on there with a tiny little meatball
taco sauce it's called taco are you
trying to make this sound delicious or
terrible because right now it's it's not
it's kind of both simultaneously okay
okay
oh oh oh is that mine that doesn't work
you need like two or use that one wait a
second maybe we just I know really Phil
is gonna frown on this okay I'm just
gonna add this to our space T space team
Joe suppose two guys for space team now
here's the thing we're just gonna have
I'm gonna get this thing right here
we're gonna get crazy up in here
there's just rappers I love I leave for
two hours and this place goes to hell
pineapple is good on pizza thank you are
you gonna do two simultaneously I was
well I was thinking this is more like
the general bit like anybody could reach
over here you know do we have insurance
trouble is my middle name all right here
we go guys get ready for space team in
[Music]
space teams all right here you go and by
the way at home if you don't have a lot
of friends is the way you can play space
team just with yourself and that really
gives you a window into my child there
you go
I like the Alita status you were all
better than your friends as we know that
he's you're watching she's a sleeper
supervillain watch this one watch this
one with those pants as our supervillain
pants yeah yeah that's right that's what
a supervillain wears someone called The
Mummy Returns little mummy action going
on somebody says what from India man Cal
is saying who would put chocolate on
rice I put chocolates delicious on rice
yeah specially like sticky rice oh man
so
yeah what are we talking about thank you
Dad
so so far space team is I think we're
starting we're loading unloading we're
all loading all right oh here we go
we're all in Oh guys look at this we got
oh look at this we got our speech team
up here - oh man I'm nervous don't worry
the ship flies itself just follow the
instructions they're alive she wants the
cetacean they're lying
I'll take pizza shots look at those
greasy tablets yeah you're right we
should get a mark of oh okay oh my god
this is such a mistake okay we could do
it though guys teamwork
chang dai-chien three one two three
check dad's here we go next techno
bellows oh my god inflate Nova scanner
who's got the Nova scanner engaged pause
reactor engage possible connect Giga
vortex connected antique lamp on connect
Giga vortex connected set fold pin to
toe that's me
grease hollow throttle it's activated
dude set full pin zero activate dark
stick oh that's this engage reactor
reactor engage grease hollow throttle
brake engaged vapor meters on here okay
disabled hi pistol launcher disabled oh
my god oh yeah what is going on mixed
techno bellows it's a weekend somehow
all right guess not way more stress now
you get to take this one Oh potato all
right here we go it's tough
I'm not gonna lie to you it's hell on
earth
it's the worst thing we've ever
attempted okay here we go I hate myself
okay here we go
GM ultra gaffer also got four jams set
flux bottle one one zero milta two cent
microcircuit two one microcircuit one I
don't see zero bill I got it I got the
zero milk enables enable meta device
starting one one set star beam two three
it's a crate wrench clamp secrete the
robot I did what's voted to decreased
our beam to zero
disable auto thumb disabled on a thumb
set dark path grid two one fires set the
door vigorous fire spark break set darn
that backwards a to dark path Brenda to
engage speaker sister arrow key is on to
zero Mella set dark path grid to two
sets to set let's go to one decrease
flexball to zero zero one set arrow key
to seven dark path grant arrow key is on
seven dark path grade two zero zero dark
mass coming in April Sun stun laser stun
laser enabled Haley on scanner to one
set arrow key to two arrow key to 2-0
mil that's zero Mella - we did it
hyperspace guys/girls god this is so
much harder than their - oh my god you
know you're you've got the best pants
warlock this is 100% not Mario Kart I
don't know if you've ever seen the exact
opposite of couldn't be my god here we
see construction it's like working in a
steel mill in the sixties it's not
really like that is it
block on activate multi hydrant
I got slot activated turn ons on a break
actually multiplayer activated increased
on flute two three interview Tesla does
turn on lambic turn on ultra ram turn on
ultra ram anyone anyone have an alter
rebbe turn on mega mega engines anyone
turn off lambic flange turn off turn on
mega max enable ball buckle engage bed
pad set quest plymouth needle yeah
interview test subjects turn on za to
brake turn ons on a break turn-ons on a
break disengage plot flush disengage
claw flesh a Dino magnet launched
disengaged flush
if it quits turned on enable Bulba Bulba
we got space team we gots me you know
what you had the hardest one though do I
got a posthumous medal for nothing I
didn't get a bottle
I guess I'm just terrible your dad saved
one unnecessary chicken just 20
hi guys I might have tried to step out
that necessary
I was really interesting but I've done
that's one thing I I avoided the sound
fun
anything I probably was
yeah all right one more space team I
think we got trouble Morrison Franklin
rod I would recommend it also I'm stuck
in like psychedelic mood yeah that's I
don't know what's going why would it
keep flipping back and forth that was
crazy
we accomplished nothing in the
university still in danger by love space
junk we leave there that's true that's
true space junk guys it's a real thing
it'll eventually get burned up by stars
stop space junk I will big hugs from
Tennessee what time is it in Tennessee
early to bed early to rise makes a
person healthy wealthy and a fee around
the eyes puffy around the eyes yeah
that's what it is you really need to
like put on one of those ice masks it
helps cucumbers or something you know
yeah you're gonna want to detox your
face I need to peel there exactly spirit
thoughts about video games end oh that's
right playing them that's right lady
games this is the team cocoa Google Play
24-hour mobile marathon for this guy and
love it I have to look at the sign every
time I have a member okay that's sorry
hey crowns bees we're just playing some
space team great game I especially like
because when you start you do like a I
made like a new game people do people
find her new password oh yeah I mean it
is up on the screen one more space team
let's do it let's do it
you want me to take the big pad I'll
take the big pad over here you've done
enough Diana to Sri Lanka in the house
that's awesome baby Jeff Goldblum is on
it yes I am baby
Oh is our paper calling you baby just
yeah it's true
called for worse about labeling jr.
Harrison's to jeff goldblum jr.
America's fine maybe that guy wants to
team cocoa podcast couldn't have been a
nicer and more handsome gentleman in
person he's he's entrancing no wait a
second they saw a password now there's
more space people yes jerks I would love
to play with them but I think the delays
are making it work yeah you know what
let's try let's give it a shine but
here's the problem this one only has
four people yeah you can use it to pay
attention alright bring us down no this
is not yeah yeah here's the thing guys I
don't think this is gonna work but if
you're in our space team lobby
I guess type it out I don't even know
what to say this is gonna be a mess oh
you know I can read it cuz I'm I don't
think I can get in the waiting room we
didn't close I just like tweaking out
I'm getting like electric shock you know
what I think people are playing space
team without us so maybe we just start
over there's gonna be like no I'm just
ready give you a bunch currently only
are you here just like this dude he's
got like a fedora
he's an x-man like a bounty hunter he
calles yeah like kind of like a really
crappy boner Pizza sites and you all
suck all I need and says m'kay now see
here's the problem the pad is showing
[Music]
that's a pass out I'm making executive
station pants out get out of here man
how do I leave
thanks it right pads out all right here
we go we're gonna we're gonna we're
gonna speak now there's four of us in
here does that mean there's there's one
straggler pad I'm getting out of here
and coming back in getting outta here
and coming back in all right here we go
we're gonna play one more around a space
team and then we're gonna we're gonna
check in with our manseok there are a
lot of games on these cells right now
that's right challenger you had some
weird childhood dreams streaming that
tablet I should have just specified the
time of day
yeah we're video phones that was
something I really know that's I dreamed
about I play live touch the dragon so
not some kids I dreamed about I saw this
weird nightmare with snakes with
antennas for eyes and bat wings for
years did you guys I did hear about that
yeah I meant to ask you as it is for I
yeah it's great like antennas came out
their eyes I don't want to get into my
nightmare dreams but I will I'll talk
about it all day
I need to spread the word about these
nightmares that are out there oh yeah
you were talking with Ruiz something I
watched too much Alien Resurrection is a
child that came out when I was like 25
the key for lucid dreaming yeah you're
supposed to look at a watch or a clock
no it'll always be like weird looking
well then that like triggers you think
like oh I'm dreaming right now cuz like
the clock hands are going like this well
I don't know why that's like a universal
human thing but uh that's crazy
alright now we know all right you're re
behind Dannic is already not in our
space t me team I'm gonna give this I'm
gonna give this 30 more seconds and
space team are you listening to me if
you can't figure your stuff out we're
just gonna not play you and we're gonna
go to the tape
oh space team signal integrity was lost
all right well guys it is who changed
the clock to army time yeah it's not
even correct it's not even right army
time it says 4:00 p.m. right now guys
good lord
all you have to do is just not touch the
clock and it would work fine what time
is it
it's it's great for am it's time to
check in with the man the one the only
Conan O'Brien let's see okay here we go
four o'clock a.m. here's the Conan
Russian doll okay
and oh it's a bad noise I got a whale
these Andy Richter look at him we're in
a weird cap I don't know why he's
working that cap and the glasses he
never wears on the air but there he is
Andy Richter is the next Russian nesting
doll oh that's an unpleasant sound hold
on a second
oh and look he's playing uh he's playing
up what's called a balalaika
it's a Russian instrument
not beautiful now the question is who's
inside Andi that sounded dirty I think
we all know who's been inside Andi
listen you think that's gross okay well
my peoples turning against me you're
gonna have to find out when you tune in
it five and you have to cuz you have to
know yes you have to know this is one of
those things where I got just like the
Super Bowl you have to watch it live
who's next
welcome back everyone to the 24-hour
mobile marathon sponsored by google play
it is 4:00 a.m. we are going strong I've
eaten like nine pieces of pizza there's
a disembodied head floating around thank
you to John dan I can Diana Chang for
holding down the fort last couple hours
the bandage hangs is uh there amazing if
you're in Los Angeles go see them
they're incredible and right now we got
a very special treat for you
and by very special I mean extremely
special not just for you but for me
personally uh this is one of my favorite
bands of all time
their name is they might be giants and
they are what a really good friend of
our show they've been on our show ever
since the old late night days and they
were nice enough to come in and do a
exclusive for song set that's right a
four song set for us we're gonna play it
for you right now the songs before I'm
just gonna do some now before we get
into the thing we're gonna we're gonna
take a look at older I like fun
Tippecanoe and Tyler too that's one song
and a self called no we're a classic I
believe off the old birdhouse LP if I'm
not mistaken and so it's they might be
giants exclusive performance right here
on the mobile marathon we'll see you
guys very soon enjoy everybody hey
they're Team Coco where they might be
giants from Brooklyn New York and here's
the song we do it's called I like fun
[Music]
patiently I wait to refill my
prescription and count the top
the drugs your car
prototype they say to combat my
affliction extra gravity
control me
[Applause]
[Music]
but that's my fun
I like fun and so do you
I need more ways over you
[Applause]
my excellence at parkour is not to be
discounted as I leap away my excellence
at parkour might be on expected but not
to you
[Music]
not
[Music]
I kind of muffed the thing in the middle
tiny bit but like really showed humanity
it's actually do older hey Team Coco
here's a song by they might be giants
it's called older
[Music]
you're older than you've ever been and
now you're even older and now you're
even older and now you're even older
you're older than you've ever been and
now you're even older time is marching
and
[Music]
is still marching
[Music]
this day will soon be at an end and now
it's even sooner and now it's leavin
sooner and now it's even sooner this
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
we're older than you've ever been and
now you're even older now you're even
now you're older you're older than
you've ever been and now you're even
older and now you're older still you
know mediator I'll try um hey Team Coco
its they might be giants we got a song
from your groove onthis hey babes babes
so uh hi Team Coco where they might be
giants we got a song from the Year 1844
you it's called Tippecanoe and Tyler too
[Applause]
Oh
who is her the great commotion motion
motion all the country it is the ball
rolling on for Tippecanoe and Tyler too
with movies little bamm-bamm fantasy use
of man
let them talk about hard cider cider
cider and luck adverse to will only go
to speed them all for Tippecanoe when
Tyler
[Music]
like the rush of mighty waters waters
waters and the course
[Music]
explosion it's it's for the internet
nobody are we losing our light we can go
again right just go again right yeah
this whole discussion about whether
we're doing a video or a taping more
that domain and yeah marty was sad
Barney was setting on so straight it's
not a tasting tape
I'm telling it's all just future
landfill that's music today it will not
last hey Team Coco it's John and John
and Kurt and Marty frumm they might be
giants all the way from Brooklyn New
York here out of our comfort zone in Los
Angeles we want to thank everybody for
being so nice this song is called a self
called know where I'm sitting on the
curb
of the empty parking lot of the store
where they let me play the organ I'm
waiting for my ride but I want to wait
inside the store where they let me play
the are
but I'm at the vanishing diner back let
me take you
the dotted lines around
No
[Music]
sucking hair
[Music]
now
[Music]
standing in my yard
when they tie down the garage
to make room for the Tong down garage
the
[Music]
but I must have so
when I needed to buy and
oh yeah
but I'm
now with
[Music]
suck in
No
[Music]
[Music]
in the back
[Music]
shut up
no way
[Music]
[Music]
to expand the format even though we act
like we're in pain everybody welcome
back to the 24-hour mobile marathon
sponsored by Google Play thank y'all for
joining us what are you guys think about
this shirt what's our opinion on this
shirt it's got a bunch of Tigers on it
and and you got leaves on there you got
I don't know what's happening um here's
a nice little backstory about this shirt
that doesn't actually even fit me it's a
little too tight I got one of those
services you know like where they send
you clothes you know for us lazy dude
shoppers and they're like oh we're gonna
make it cool we're gonna send you cool
clothes and I was like great
they sent me so many clothes that were
so expensive and I just out of all the
stuff they sent me I kept sending stuff
back and it went back and forth and it
started getting like embarrassing cuz
they assign you a person they send you
like a stylist it sounds like well what
do you like and I'm like I like this
kind of stuff it's just like oh and
she'd send me a bunch of this stuff and
I we'd all be hundreds of dollars or so
finally out of guilt I just a guilt of a
person I've never met we'll never meet I
owe nothing to it was a service I bought
this shirt it was so expensive I've
never worn it because it doesn't really
fit the sleeves are a little too short
it's like weirdly pokes at my stomach
and it's got Tigers on it and I bought
it and there was no reason for me to
ever wear it and now I'm wearing on the
stream so I hope you're all happy I look
neat list says you I look like I could
sell you a good car all right cool do
car salesman where a lot of tiger shirts
that's something I didn't know but you
know what we're learning stuff on this
street including don't buy a tiger shirt
just out of guilt
ah so we're gonna play a game next an
offshoot well one of my favorite games
of all time
fallout shelter you can't tell by the
amazing eye look how what I love anybody
tuning in right now this looks totally
nuts I don't have any bruises on my arm
I know it's all just nerve damage at
this point oh how many bruises I don't
think although there is kind of a rash
developing which is fun
sure it's hella cool thank you cozy with
Sarkozy good morning from Mexico hey
Jorge how's it going
ooh zennith says every time I see if
don't know what this guy's face I have
to buy a new monitor because it makes me
violently kick it that's a weird way to
be aroused but you know what we've all
got our things I love it
you have fallout 4 VR how is it is it
awesome I bet you it is
whoo the idea of my fault
dun dun am I just picking my own vault
what am I doing here
alright I can just pick any vault feels
played this so when you hear it that's
what that's filss I'm guessing saying
yes vault 69 good one Metcalfe that's a
little obvious thirty four and a half
you know a little bit better
mmm let's see good morning from Morocco
holy Moses good morning Morocco morning
from Tucson hey Maria pine stylist which
I guess I know you're asking me
Brendan lil I know you guys are talking
about I'm reading all the chats so if
you think you can say something without
me seeing it good luck because I see it
all I see it all all right I'm gonna go
let's just pick a number at random and
that random number I will pick very
carefully and it will be double-oh-seven
which is like James Bond it's the secret
agent fault all right here we go
I'm the overseer of vault 7 cool the
vault I also I love one thing I love
about the font aesthetic it's like the
retro a steampunk Ian kind of old slide
stuff I love this it's over here my job
is to expand and maintain the vault
while keeping my dwellers safe and happy
well I used to make camp counselor so
how hard could this be
okay each vault
each room is a special attribute it uses
assigned to others but I couldn't read
that okay
fall out you gotta give me some thing
here vault-tec will give you a daily
rating based on your performance
remember to keep your dollars happy and
do a great job please stand by okay all
right now you'd rather eat bees than
play this game okay well duly noted
lunchbox I've never actually eaten a bee
I would 100% you to be heavy Nance
I've eaten crickets before not the
crickets that live in my apartment those
are different I just take those and
throw them outside my wife anybody in
this dream I don't want to make this
about me says the guy in the tiger shirt
sitting on a green screened couch but if
anyone knows how to get rid of crickets
out of their apartment let me know
because I got a lot of crickets in my
apartment and they're really loud I
don't really mind them they're not like
eating up my apartment like a termite
but they're loud man and it's hard to
sleep all right after I just basically
asked Google if we could have this
stream so I could sleep at the office
without arousing suspicion so that's the
thing helpful hints welcome to your new
vault overseer let's introduce you to
the basic concepts let's let's build a
room okay sighing dwellers here to
produce power okay
I'm gonna build a generator ooh I can
build different rooms
all right let's build one on the first
use a flamethrower I don't have a flint
area
okay we need dwellers you think we got
to get busy you know making some
dwellers mmm
further explain more in turn into
intricately what goes on inside my brain
cage I don't know man my mind's a pretty
scary place I probably shouldn't be in
there alone
Zachary Clarke sounds like a fine fellow
trying to out a tap and a hold the Droid
and drag them to a room Oh God okay
you're gonna be in this room when the
power generator just built we're up why
not put the power generator on the first
floor that was dumb all right there we
go get in there buddy who's gonna be
what game should you get says Heisenberg
I don't know we played a lot of great
games tonight played Monument Valley to
which I loved
put that with Conan we played some
lumiose city I know we played some space
team with Danny and Chang that was great
home remedies for crickets oh no it's
one bite too fast
traps are on the prowl no I look back
too fast can you post that again home
remedies for cricket what's my childhood
nickname guys my Charlie nickname kids
can be so cruel
peanut butter and belly that's right
it got laughs from the crew but that's
true also a frosty because not because
of my white hair because I had terrible
dandruff like a snowman and you wonder
why I bought this shirt and went into
comedy that's why kids all right and it
was only after I came to Conan that
people started calling me bleh which i
think is a pretty good nickname
ah bleh that's right then there's a lady
wait oh there's a lady waiting yes sorry
the ladies out here can't keep the
ladies waiting okay a signer to the
generator room so far this game is
action-packed nothing like the
apocalypse to make you want to just run
out into the wasteland all right what's
happening here
we're gonna tap and hold and then drag
the person here we go got her all right
I'm pulling I'm basically pulling her
soul over to this room this is kind of
deep guys Thank You Madeline I love you
too
where's your red-haired God I think he's
probably right now sleeping in the green
room he doesn't have a house that's a
lot of people don't know that about
Conan he doesn't own a home he sleeps
here actually on the stage and we have
to wake him up every morning hey Coney
get out of here go to props and shower
what about Taco Coco that doesn't make
any sense
wisten so I'm not gonna answer that
question because it's not a question you
just said tuck you just said what about
taco coke I didn't make that how are we
on Eric well I'd love to tell you the
hour but some Nimrod gave us the Rudy do
and the old razzamatazz and twist our
clock say army time but army time where
it's like in the afternoon so it says
1624 what is that 424 I guess it's
actually pretty easy you just subtract
12 but I'm tired man I want to subtract
well that's what much time I have left
oh no no up top here Rob job here at
7:35 yeah no I was talking about this
weird red a clock over here that I hate
that I would love to destroy during this
stream and I'm like yes we have seven
hours 34 minutes 52 seconds and you know
it's kind of nice seeing as a countdown
because it makes me think that Tom isn't
just standing still which after you've
been in this room for more than 10
minutes it feels like just you've always
been here Jack Torrance it's like The
Shining
okay boilers are working the room will
start producing resources double tap and
a room to take a closer look whoa look
at this Sandra's got some dope hair
going on
Zachary the butt part not a good look I
had that Middle School where you just
part it here and part of here it looks
tired
darah need of extra resources I don't
care about the rush mode that's fine by
the way typical situation the guy doing
nothing the woman doing all the work
look at this he's just all he's doing is
like filling out a clipboard ridiculous
all right hard work is happy work I
don't agree with that at all I think
light work is happy work that's coding
in a play again big smokes I do believe
he will I did I just assumed Sanders
gender you know what I'm sorry you're
right I did assume a gender I agree we
live in a post gender society where
gender is fluid and not binary thing but
she's just cooler so I assumed that
she's a woman because women are cool
bleh what's this on old video of me
wrestling well I'm surprised that you
managed to stop throwing up because that
was a gross video of me jumping around
real sweaty real sweaty then we wanted
to see that who try eucalyptus essential
oil for my cricket problem thank you
well what game is this wisdom we're
playing fallout shelter and so far jams
awesome all right we did it
let's build a second room all right now
I'm gonna put the diner
I don't want to put an X to the power
generator because I feel like that's
just it's terrible idea so let's put it
kind of underneath the ground although
we're just gonna attract bugs very amass
any games you guys wish you'd done close
game around I wish we'd done gate it's
hard because I I wish we did close
gamers for all the games because it's
super fun I know that's a non-answer but
it's true I'll tell you games I don't
like doing for clueless gamer how about
that I don't like doing games I actually
really want to play in real life because
it ruins it for me it ruins the game
because I have to play I have to see
like the end of the game I play the
entire game although there are a couple
games for instance like Smash Brothers
we played Super Smash Brothers for close
gamer and that one the game was only
twenty percent done when they gave it to
us so I literally couldn't see all the
games it wasn't done what games I'm
looking forward to I'm gonna tell you
what games looking forward to we got
some great games coming up in this
stream very very excited coming up a
little bit later
I love it Super Mario run is a super
super fun game and I'm not even gonna
get to play it our next two guests that
are coming in every time I look at that
clock I'm gonna smash it in the face at
five we have two more guests coming in
and they're gonna I you know what I'm
the giver and so my favorite games I
give to other people except for fallout
shelter which is awesome Ozzy Ozzy I
think if you're asking if anyone's
falling asleep in a chat that does make
any sense because you what are you
talking about they're sleeping they're
not gonna look into chat I can eat the
crickets that's true I could eat the
crickets crickets are delicious I've had
them full salt on him you know fry him
right up well see we already got rats
I knew putting the diner underground was
a bad idea alright so I got more folks
here let's just stick them everybody
wants to come into my vault man it's
like a dope nightclub we got going on
let's get him in here now is there any
sort of test I think in real life if I
had a vault I would make some you know
cuz you don't want to let anybody in
there willy-nilly you know you want
people with skills you got to give them
some kind of some kind of test so I
probably give them a trivia test and
probably like about my life because if
I'm like the head of this vault I want
people to like me you know know a little
bit about what they're getting into and
probably be a lot of questions about
comic books because you know in the post
apocalypse you want people to be able to
the similar interest is yours to talk
about stuff yeah I know helpful hen I
could send people to explore the
wasteland I want to get everybody in
here first before I send them out to do
stuff okay so this room I kind of like
how the graphics are really cool like I
like how they put like the the 2d
animation over like this 3d layout is
pretty dope we have Denise again I'm not
assuming a gender gregory's got a mohawk
trying a little too hard Gregory if you
ask me
all right power generator doke oh can I
upgrade there we go I think it's good to
have a lot of power right guys I was
trying to chat her up and she's like oh
I don't really like guys with Mohawks do
you really like me oh my god you're so
desperate Gregory dude what's your deal
man I just chill out you just got to be
cool nobody likes a desperate thirsty
mohawked post-apocalyptic wanderer style
is still important in the apocalypse
your true mask of that mask of quaint
quaint I don't know how to say her name
because it's 4:00 a.m. it's right it's
all I guess Aaron it's all perfectly
normal
it's Denise this game has potential
Robert Haberfeld I think this game I've
heard really good things about this game
okay well I'm just gonna leave these two
to chat it up all right what do we got
going on down here she's just figuring
out this pipe situation hey Cheryl how's
it going I don't have calves oh I see oh
she it's gonna take her a minute 28
seconds to fix this pipe you know what I
don't want to tell what's your name I
don't tell Cheryl Hart how to do her job
but maybe just going like this with a
pipe you know I use two hands I don't
know I mean this just barely working
this is ridiculous
come on Cheryl put your back into it
I think Cheryl's just not cut out for
water treatment plant work I'm just
gonna put it out there meanwhile Gregory
over here she's clearly not interested
look look how dead her eyes are I've
never seen dead her eyes Denise for it
she's like yeah uh-huh
what's that oh yeah your paper bag
collection that's so cool actually I did
collect paper bags when I was a kid
that's actually a true story we went to
Niagara Falls this is a very sad true
story but I feel like it's 4:30 a.m. and
I can tell it on a public stream
I collected paper bags as a child
a very sad childhood you know like you
go to the store and you get a cool paper
bag maybe it's got a handle on it you
know don't judge me you don't know me
you do actually know everything about me
cuz I put my life on the Internet but we
went to Niagara Falls as a kid and I got
a really cool paper bag and on the way
home I wanted to put it in my carry-on
luggage my parents told me to put it in
the check luggage it got ripped
I was inconsolable I had a sad childhood
guys what can I say
I love my paper bags and then when I was
at home I put them all up on the wall
this is now that I'm saying it out loud
it's really sad but as a kid I love my
paper bag collection I have to go back
I'll they're our but they don't have the
same paper bags Co people collect paper
bags
okay I'm not so weird there we go there
we go
Jordan does have eyes that are that's
right sigh Kuno here this is the worst
game to play on a live stream I don't
know man we're having a good time I mean
watching two people try to hook up is
pretty hilarious I gotta say even if
they are just cartoons Jody Rose I'm
glad you asked the paper bag it was
white and it had red trim around it but
the cool thing about it is it had this
like Sheen to it and I didn't have any
other paper bags that had a cool sheen
so I was really excited and you know
what ruins a sheen or rip and that's
what happened so kids I'm saying out
there quick PSA the more you know if
you're bringing something home that's
fragile like a paper bag for your paper
bag collection cuz you have a very sad
childhood no friends putting your
carry-on luggage don't put it in your
check luggage don't do it even when your
parents tell you to yay caps people
jumping up and down do I get to go kill
things in this game oh here we go
she's back on the pipe everybody I guess
that could be considered a drug
reference but I'm not gonna pretend
because I'm innocent
I don't know what
okay uh-oh we got this dude I'm not let
this dude in this guy does not get into
my fault this this is every guy in my
neighborhood every time I go to a bar in
my neighborhood it's this dude his name
is usually like zero or something you
know or like Xander with an X or two x's
B's music yes we should play the Friday
13th game at some point not in the
stream but soon it's like a Robbie
Williams song put a bag inside a bag
inside a bag I don't know Williams we're
all weird kids Eric fine we're all weird
kids what's something weird that you did
besides collecting weirder than paper
bag collecting what I prefer a plastic
bag or a paper bag I you know what it's
not there's not that many cool plastic
bags out there I'm gonna be honest
really the art the artisanal paper bag
is what you want when you're collecting
paper bags I can't believe we're talking
about paper bags in this stream and I
can't believe I told you guys I
collected paper bags as a child that's
my fault okay as is this shirt this is
what you get when you feel guilty that
your stylist you haven't bought anything
your stylist in six months okay and I by
the way I quit that service because they
would send me shirts like this okay
let's go let's get this lady out I'm
gonna get what's his girl is this Cheryl
did she finally stop talking no this is
Brittany okay Brittany we're gonna put
you out in the wasteland
yeah we're gonna pull her out way over
here oh whoops
oh look you've been telling me to send
my people out to the waistline nice
equip them now fine well how do I do
that how do I equip how I quit ball
Brittany we're gonna give Brittany out
here oh I see we do this okay she needs
a weapon how do we equip her with a
weapon anyone
what's this thing I need a screwdriver
god I don't don't ask me Kelly you know
what I'm just creating a really annoying
society of people who can't fix pipes
and trying to chat each other up this is
terrible this is just like camp but I
was a camp counselor I need to build a
weapon how do I do that not moy Blin
how do I build a weapon there's rats in
the diner knows some mess she's working
on that pipe Oh God please
you got it Cheryl you got to finish this
plate 20 seconds till Cheryl finishes we
got a sign she'll do something else cuz
she'll is just absolutely killing me all
right here we go
where's the weapon maker thing wait
science lab oh we need 16 dwellers that
means I gotta let in zero up here I have
a strictly no hipster policy in my
evolved but I guess I just need the
people this is like when a nightclub
first opens you know like at like a like
8 o'clock now that's the only time I
could ever get in because I wear shirts
like this and I used to collect paper
bags and I'm not cool so quick tip guys
if you want to get into cool nightclubs
go really early when they open and they
still want people to go in like I'm
talking like 5 p.m. like go get like the
early bird me little your local diner
steak and eggs I'd recommend cuz you
wanted something Hardy for dancing and
then I go straight to the nightclub
before the sun's even gone down I like
to get to the nightclub about 4:00 4:30
you know you can help put away the
chairs from the night before I'd like to
get this person in my vault please drag
their sole living quarters okay that's
cool
here we go living quarters boom I don't
have enough caps okay great
oh my god all right I need more calves
and to get Oh God
okay low on power
okay long food loan water you know what
I need to put some people in this diner
I think we gotta get this food we're not
getting any food mate
Ethan what the hell is even Oh Ethan's
the dude I hate that's zero all right
guess what do you think get down there
and make some food could you and you
know what put a put a go team net over
that disgusting thing on your face
[Music]
what a mess all right
don't rip myself for it I think that was
supposed to be a paper bag joke but I'm
sorry felt a little flat gobble library
I'd rather go to bingo night after my
early bird meal you know what bingo
nights way more fun than nightclub night
clubs are boring guys need that oh here
we go
have you seen my best friend what's
going on here I say you guys are here to
make food and you're just wiping a table
and playing across or possible oh wait
the food supply all right how do I meet
more food me power
I need to make these guys are supposed
to be making food but instead they're
just chatting each other up
enough caps that's cool diner
yeah let's rush it there we go
rush it up make that food make that food
I see okay we're doing it guys really
doing it we've got 123 caps I have a
special guy outside oh I don't know I
need more living quarters I think right
but I got a I got to make more food
before I could have more living quarters
Oh
Gemma's back up here we go did you sleep
it off alright nice nice let's see here
am I gonna play brave frontier
Heisenberg I might who knows that you'll
young this is fallout shelter a splinter
of the game fallout of the popular
post-apocalyptic series and so far it's
just making me really angry because no
one's doing their jobs look they're just
walking around this doodie now what is
going on baby who cares about the Sun
I'm the only light oh my gosh
what are they going to bang in the back
wait smiley faces that's crazy oh oh I
think the roommates gonna walk in on
them oh that was really quick
whoa now she's pregnant already oh crap
I don't know if the people who made this
game know huh how sex works this is
crazy
she's already preggers oh my god
she just looks sad she's like all like
oh man you let that guy with a mohawk
have sex with you oh boy
poor choice is already being made in
this vault I'm not doing a good job as
overseer guys this is terrible she's
wandering around you're not even
providing for your child Gregory is your
name Gregory
yeah Gregory Owens ah this guy with a
mohawk you know he's one of those cool
dads you ever see those cool dad's like
barbed wire tattoos it's like alright
man we get it like you don't need to be
you're a father you could just be a
normal guy you don't need to be super
cool give it up you know stop listening
to Bad Brains and wearing cutoff jean
shorts hey flem of shadow what's going
on I love your name with a shirt like
that neither do I you're right I make
terrible choices we've already gone
through this Jemma missed the whole part
about my paper bag collection thank God
you can watch the stream it's a whole ID
I opened up as a just an embarrassing
thing to my childhood and now I'm being
punished for it by the stream that's
what I get that's what I get we're still
low on food you know why cuz these two
guys won't do anything you're killing me
you're killing me smalls this I knew I
shouldn't let this go t do to my thing
it look at this guy of course he was
gonna do anything can't even comb his
hair hey you're welcome flame of shadow
great name use that lunch box what's the
lunch box
I'm rushing to room again we're doing it
I love how by the way every time I rush
a room the incident of fire goes up 45%
that's me when I cook by the way every
single time the chances of me burning
down my house go up
I've also burned myself really bad
making creme not creme brulee what's the
other thing that's called what's up it's
something that's called not flambe flan
I made flan it was terrible
where's a flan nobody knows bullpup yes
I did write the how to lose weight
before easy steps and step 5
buy a dumb-looking shirt and then no
woman will approach you after you've
lost weight burritos Thank You Ellen
you're a bot I wish I had burritos too
all right we got food I'm gonna rush it
again man 55 I know I might start a fire
but I think we just need this food we
maximize production great work all right
we got a lot of calves I think we gotta
upgrade this oh god we can't upgrade it
yet
flan the burn was horrid yeah some
people saw that burn it was terrible I
had a blister the size of like Rhode
Island on my finger give you a kiss
that's impossible I mean come to the
studio I'll give you a kiss in person
big smokes and I would say that's RJ but
RJ is about to come on screen everybody
so it can't be in the chat rolling me
hey Cindy Wes you have to put that cheek
on that's just walking around into a
room that doesn't make sense I don't
think I look like cable that's really
nice of you to say cuz cable is a pretty
Josh Brolin's a pretty good-looking dude
even with a scarred up face and I said
this before but I'm not impressed by
warriors with like a lot of scars you
know because that means you're a
terrible warrior because you're getting
just like hit by everybody you have a
lot of scars you're at their terrible
war that doesn't make you tougher look
amazing
you look just you know like Achilles
guys ever seen Troy Brad Pitt dreamy by
the way of that and Eric Bana it's a
it's a dream fest it's a dream fest if
you want to dream fest watch that movie
but not a scar on the guy scar on
Achilles you know why he was a great war
so they say all right these twos a
Korean I can't imagine doing anything
else in the vault that's a pretty
leading statement for a guy with a but
part on his head you know all right well
he's surely not gonna get any play I
want to see what happens with what's
going on with our our girl girl here oh
maybe I should upgrade the living
quarters right I can't yet darn it can I
make new living quarters yes I can build
it up goose ass now look at this move
look at this move now we can get invite
more people in including this very
dapper that looks like me oh my god
that's me in a suit you guys look at
this cat
Donald Powell that is 100% me look at
this look at this dude I can't point
over there but it's over that's me
we got to get this guy in here and I do
have kind of a suit that looks just like
that but to be fair I have a lot of dumb
looking suits levelling-up are people
who are quote unquote cooking just
filling out trivia it is me Madeleine
see oh man have you got it let's go to
me in the vault my name is Donald lookit
look at him you walking around there
that's great I'm I'm guessing Todd
Howard made this game and put me in it
I'm just gonna assume that he saw me
when we went to the pathetic quarters
and put me in this game thanks Todd you
too man
you demand my boy Todd my point on
Howard doing it up pretty great that's a
handsome-looking devil right there
although you know what he could stand
he's got terrible posture feel like I'm
you know shoulders back retract the
scapula
hey quick tip if you didn't know you can
build two of the same room together to
make a much larger room oh darn it
alright well well played I'm gonna do
that right now I need more water we have
what's your face working on the water
situation which is not going very well
let's get another person down here into
the water thing you're gonna go down
there what yeah get down there you know
what I man also I think it's time Donald
gets down there
let's get other people working on this
water you know I think we need also more
people working on the old food thing I
don't want to put a pregnant woman to
work but so I'm gonna take her hubby and
get him down there only two people can
work in a room at a time damn it oh damn
it hi I'm Ted you know what I'm as good
at this game as I was being a camp
counselor which is to say I was terrible
I'm just gonna put it out there I didn't
want to admit it on the livestream but I
was horrible I was really bad I was a
bad influence I kept my kids up all
night with scary stories which are just
basically stories about me having a
paper bag that wasn't you know not a
good I played a lot of Beastie Boys I
would play what's the one that it starts
like a dog barking I played that every
morning the entire summer to wake my
campers up they hated it they absolutely
hated it but I loved it cuz I loved the
Beastie Boys or just Beastie Boys which
is their
okay so I see what you mean so I need to
build more I really didn't plan this
vault out very well I'm not and I never
said I was a good vault planner to be
fair please read your other message
flame of shadow what was your other
message make a rap album snot rod I did
make a rap album in my bedroom called
the Cobras and I'm gonna tell you why we
called our selves the Cobras cuz went
out of the East Village we lived in a
place called the snake pit I lived it
with two other guys and the reason I was
called a snake pit is it was long and
narrow like a snake and we never cleaned
it up and it was a pit and it didn't
have any windows except for the ends and
it smelled like dude in there like to a
crazy degree people would come over just
be like you would see as soon as they
cross the threshold the Musk would hit
them kind of like a like a wet paper
towel soaked in like warm water just
like like right in the face like a face
hugger you know it was gross and then
they'd already come in and they didn't
want to be roots they'd have to stay and
you just just taste on their face the
entire time but I live there and it was
gross
also I live this is a true story I lived
the apartment building backed up to a
Kentucky Fried Chicken not a Kentucky
Fried Chicken can tacky Fried Chicken
they actually took a Kentucky Fried
Chicken I think it went out of business
and then another business moved in and
they just took the youths and changed it
to A's so there's can tacky Fried
Chicken and it was across the street I'm
not making this up from an 11-7 I swear
to you that's true that's a true story
and I collected paper bags I'm sorry I'm
sick of this dream we're doing bad man
white guys are starving there's no water
and I'm that's me in the water thing and
I can't figure it out what am i doing
with the clipboard
I'm the worst worker ever
we're safe here in the vault uh-oh
applause no deathclaws r about ah cozy
with Sarkozy it was actually uh they
can't hang fried chicken was delicious I
mean any fried chicken is good what are
we doing I'm not picky about fried
chicken something in New York and
smelled like dude once okay I don't know
what that means
dude is the smell it's build another
room for food and build another one
right next to it okay good idea
I don't know if I could build anything
right now though Canada I don't have any
caps man we're in a capitalist world
where we got some problems over here man
we got people not working oh they're
just talking about their pets how do I
kick these people in the bum
[Music]
oh no fail oh it's a disaster guys I
pushed it drag him out of the room to
keep him alive
I'll they put it out already I made the
other people work harder so maybe you
know what I need to threaten my vault
while there's a danger this is how a
dictatorship start I can see it right
now to get your workers its BC boys to
what you want there that's exactly what
it is great
groundbreaking saw a melindam a Mickle
burg is that your real name Melinda may
Mick Middleburg is great yeah I can't
build another room yet everybody I also
if you want to know where I got this
shirt I got it from a service that sends
you clothes but I was way too they just
sent me so many clothes I didn't buy
anything and then finally I bought this
shirt and I spent my life savings on it
and that's the first time I've ever worn
it and probably the last time while the
comments I've been getting almonds just
screaming okay well it is almost five
o'clock there we go um all right I think
my guys are gonna starve to death and
whatever the opposite of drowning is die
of thirst
who says who I feel a bathroom break
coming on I guess John danik said he had
the ladder of a little child just saying
you have to go to the bathroom like an
adult take out the guy with one agility
merge that allows more people oh that's
such a long comment that I can't read
sorry that's right I'm watching every
look he's in though I'm reading your
comment on twitch there you go
Avengers newbie we're playing a 24-hour
we're playing a twibell games from the
Google Play Store for 24 hours we are in
our what it what are we I don't even
know 15 17 nobody knows whatever this
guy is doing exactly jack squat in here
maybe I should I don't think she's doing
anything back here but she's level two
so what am i what am I gonna do let's
rush it now let's not rush it let's just
wait 30 seconds what are some my
favorite Google Play games I'm glad you
asked I'm actually loving fallout
shelter even I'm terrible at it I think
I might actually could play this game
and not have to talk to the chat and
talk about my shirt and my terrible
paper bag habit I would actually be very
good at this game oh oh I think a guy
just came on yelling at me about
something we got more water oh that
didn't do anything
alright I'm rushing it I'm rushing it
rush it baby
andrush that we're in a rush this food
situation and I'll failed no this is bad
oh no we starting another fire Oh oh my
god what's happening radroaches oh I
gotta save myself sorry oh good job you
know what I think we found something
it's Sandra's good at there Cheryl's
good at not fixing pipes but killing
radroaches that's great
Ron Tel Aviv water not fire okay fair
enough
well the power stations doing great we
got so much power you guys it's crazy I
think we need to like upgrade our water
treatment plan we don't enough caps
perfect all right this is going
extremely well you realize in about 15
seconds Oh Flemish adder that you wrote
a huge thing that I missed
I love Gaffigan does he still have a
show on he's hilarious coffee or Red
Bulls Robert I go coffee I was a Red
Bull guy I was a energy drink guy and
then I discovered coffee and coffee is
way worse for me because it makes me
insane in the membrane as the old
Cypress Hill once said that got a
chuckle from over there I heard it a
snicker exactly dad we go to the Oscars
no I've never been the Oscars 5min to
the Emmys but I've never been to the
Oscars but our good friends are a show
Kumail Nanjiani and Emily Gordon were
nominated Jordan Peele won for Best
Original Screenplay congratulations to
him amazing
get out was fantastic as was the big
sick
Ray Romano in the bait and Holly Hunter
how good were they in the big stick so
good so good
we got a slow clap over there that's all
we can manage five I am the slowest of
claps
I'm happy that we're all gonna play this
game for four more minutes you know I'd
need to see all my vault dwellers starve
to death which is gonna happen just
because this woman won't stop wiping a
table for God's sakes cook a piece of
food what's wrong with you
Holly honor is great I know Madeline I
can't get her to make any food how do
you get her to make food in this game
I'm gonna rush it and it's good it's 63
percent death this is gonna be bad
there's gonna be something's gonna
something Bad's gonna happen the guy's
gonna come on I knew it
see I told you I could tell that was
gonna happen the rooms on fire great to
be fair this is a lot like when I cook
so it's kind of familiar to me I finally
feel it oh they jumped up and down nice
now why don't you guys cook some oh no
back to work just filling out our
crossword and wiping a table don't worry
everyone else is starving good lord I'm
over here look at how sad I am sad I am
this is me right now in real life this
is exactly you're seeing me sad in real
life and in the game pretty great guys
pretty amazing we got a big lineup out
here these ladies are maybe they think
this is a nightclub and I I wish this
was it'd be way more fun you're not
doing anything
uh-oh she's not feeling too good Oh No
oh my god this game is getting dark you
know let's put this girl down here and
let's put you got power these guys are
just killing it I don't the Power Team
is that's the right thing to do you know
what let's get let's get me out of here
cuz I'm not doing anybody any good let's
get somebody in here with some some
skills here I think this this chick is
uh let's put her over here there we go
all right
oh my god did your father sell diamonds
cuz you're flawless this is how I'm
hitting on a girl in a game
Oh No oh this is awful
this is probably what it looks like to
other people when I'm at a bar talking
to somebody else that's this is the face
I make I'm just like I shouldn't be out
in public in this shirt I do normally
wear a vault Ella dweller suit also by
the way Sam Rock will be an amazing
coolest gamer jacob the boy i love Sam
Rockwell's he's hilarious and a great
actor moon was amazing he was great
three billboards yeah let's let's zoom
in on me trying to hit on a girl in a
game this is great oh look at this oh
god yep this is me it looked at me just
stick you lating they nailed me here
thank good job Bethesda you really guys
got me yep by the way how soon did that
guy impregnate a woman this is never
gonna happen right here we're just
looking at this is this you man Phyllis
this is a 5 a.m. stream everybody all
right well we don't need to watch any
more of this depressing scene play out
it's 5:00 a.m. and that's right and I
think it's time to check in on mr. Conan
O'Brien let's go to Conan everybody
[Music]
welp coming to the bathroom so that was
uneventful
look even TV hosts have to go to the
bathroom once in a while so we're gonna
let him do his thing and not bother him
before we introduce our next guest we're
gonna take a look you guys look I'm
gonna be honest with you
we we tried to to summon Jordan we
didn't have the right amount of chicken
bones and voodoo to summon him from the
nether realm in which he lives instead
we're gonna take a look at the a
hilarious remote when Jordan and Conan
well I'm not gonna explain it I'll just
I'll let you watch it how about that
enjoy this amazing
Jordan Google remote earlier this week I
was forced to share a cab to the Apollo
Theater with our associate producer
Jordan shlonsky
if you're at all familiar with Jordan
you know how painful and experience that
was for me
thankfully I had my phone and one of our
sponsors Google Play to help me endure
this session take a look
Apollo Theater please Broadway was
originally named by the Dutch colony of
New Amsterdam we all stirred um back or
away was a naturally creative path
usually from heavy foot traffic or
perhaps animal why are we writing
together how did this what about you're
going in the same direction I know why
wouldn't we arrive together well you
were the moment answer that question we
wouldn't drag together because you're
such an irritating open google play do
something other than listen to you I
might play Angry Birds match right
the Broadway that was president a New
Amsterdam only went as high as boss
trapped okay which is typically called
Wall Street and in fact the reason it
was called balsa come on is because of a
wooden wall was present there to keep
out anyone north of that point I'm
playing Angry Birds match I'm not
looking at you I'm totally engaged in
this game that's a signal to most people
to maybe stop talking steam is utilities
supplied by con Edison New York City has
the highest quality tap waters in the
world the maximum theoretical
temperature of 212 degrees Fahrenheit
the American version of the bomb kochia
is a very dense spongy bread Duran Duran
had a quote in their song steam subway
which is technically incorrect I
considered the soundtrack to Footloose
to be a bit overrated I like the deep
cuts how many friends do you have
I mean real friends not concerned with
friends means no friends
Jordan appears we were at the Apollo
Theater yes and I hope I never see you
again
now the marquee above us was originally
a person analog Mark II and now of
course it's electronic but he's in a
hear me stay here
thanks for friends at Google Play for
helping us out there hey everybody
welcome back to the 24-hour mobile
marathon sponsored by Google Play ah I
don't think anybody's lay like this the
entire 24 hours so I thought I'd give
you a little taste of the full-body bleh
although not my ankles all right there
we go enough of this well let's bring on
our next two guests - hilarious
fellas you know it's Conan staffers you
know I'm his best pals
their names are r.j. cinnamon and Nick's
Centofanti good night
there you go come on in come on in come
on in come on in come on in look at this
look at this
morning morning good morning all right
guys here you go I'm gonna give you this
bad boy all right and then introduce
yourselves to the chat we got a we got
got twitch here we got Facebook there we
got an awesome there hey bear ski what's
going on how's it going oh my gosh
there's so many this is awesome all
right enjoy fellas
this is awesome good morning so it's
5:00 a.m. 5:00 a.m. and it's 8 a.m. on
the East Coast
so everybody's just eating their
pop-tarts hanging out in the morning
yeah streaming want to want you can
you're doing a 24 hour stream you always
save your best for the 5:00 a.m. all
right course what do you want to be here
peak hour what are we playing Nick
you're playing Super Mario run have you
ever played it I have played it a little
bit have you played it at all like I
know Mario is wearing my Mario hat this
is actually from the Olympics I got
obsessed with him at Hamilton the curler
the curler yeah I got obsessed with him
so I bought the head and the goal for
the first time ever so awesome he had
the coolest moustache man I can't do it
I can't grow hair right here which one
is which again this is this is Facebook
over here that's YouTube okay you do
this is twitch yeah yeah all right
we got alright first level here let's go
Oh somebody's already done this level
license dong says that Ben Affleck I
assume they're talking about down yet
there's no way they're talking about me
yes Ben ethics is not here unfortunately
this is amazing but which is the is not
it's like everything other than the show
so we're doing a show right now for TBS
called final space which is awesome
you guys check it out I think episode 2
or episode 3 just airs Monday we also
have show got people of Earth just
pretty cool love it on TBS as well hey
how's it going Robert what's going on
I've been watching all day this whole
time who yeah who has watched the long
as anyone been here just the entire time
besides who is that Robert yeah Rob guys
are come Roberts man yeah
this has been going for what this is the
17th valerie 17 hours or i think so this
is 17 or 18 late was out here he's a
machine
I don't know how his energy is still
where it is
Sydney West said that was impressive run
oh well thank you yeah lays this on if
I'm missing anything let me know I do
you know I'll miss the big coins a
spoiler what's going on
[Music]
where's our pretty from here yes from
sure everyone's a slack Oh Erin from
Spain that's awesome how's it going and
no idea a tiny woody yeah what time is
it in Spain Aaron I'm gonna guess 1:00
p.m. you could say anyway and I'm like I
need that pay you have to get the people
you have to go back but you can't go
there now it's like story of this is it
the same as every Mario where you're
just looking for Princess Peach has been
capturing I believe yet that old song
and dance
Mario that classic Sam
[Music]
and is best at this game I think you
might be do you break a record on the
stream right now does that ever happen
is this the first record broken so dream
there might be this listen you guys are
tuning in at the right Super Mario run
record well Roberts from Denver let's uh
go Daniel Connors from Connors from
Victoria British Columbia
that's one my favorite places I've ever
been to a wedding there two years ago
it's like insanely beautiful I missed
the play where you Toria British
Columbia off the coast of Vancouver okay
I think it's on Vancouver Island it's
insane it's like like the most beautiful
picture X picturesque it's too big of a
word for five of em mountains but like
right on an island in the ocean and
there's like this little quaint little
town that's beautiful it's amazing I
need to travel more I think you want to
take you gotta get your turn here this
is I mean I don't want to ruin your
record well listen yeah maybe another
time for record so this is my first time
ever playing a game on a tablet that's
real that's real what's up in Chicago
okay all right here we go
paratroopers in mushroom Valley we're
watching from Australia that's amazing
Australia
[Music]
so fun I said hey you didn't do that
once behind while you play thank me
thank you for saying that anyone save
myself but you're right I did not
it's intimidating playing with you
you're good at video games it is
refreshing to play this style game you
know video game these days it's usually
with old play and it's some like
incredible new instant no no no it's
some insane amazing game
somebody's from Kentucky just saw it
Natalie since Madeleine Sims what's up
shout out to Kentucky 8 a.m. in Kentucky
I know the time I just thought oh my
gosh one minute bubble Madeleine where
are you from and Kentucky let me know
wait I got it I got a comment on this we
related Natalie Janeway 587 says at
least you guys were better than Kramer
at games oh yes which I will take that
all day long Jane yes watching from date
I don't know you're running out of time
I'm sorry I wasn't paying attention this
is we're learning here to return no no
hello from Atlanta industry what's
everybody having for breakfast this
morning anything good toaster strudel
hos little thing
just for sure the thing is I know the
cops are Gaia yeah toasters are messy
you give the placing you make sure you
are you a pop tart with no icing guy no
don't see the pop-tart icing is like
very like dry strides yeah yeah it's a
whole one that's a good point
let's see Red Bull and a hoagie Jessie J
has okay hoagie you must be from
definitely these guys this is great
Madeline head really roasts doughnuts
that's great I don't know it's what you
want I love a girls don't know I'm
really bad at this
I mean if you don't want to save the
princess
that's on you all right nice I was just
going for time that time last time I was
messing around trying to get all the
coins
[Music]
Metcalfe F they kept me just that
college life ramen noodles yeah listen
we all ate ramen the [ __ ] you're
having Oreos I like that move like fried
hamburger Wow
what are these guys called what are the
flying show guys turtles are troopers
koopa troopas I got Zeron it's a chat
will let us know immediately if we're
wrong but I think it's a Koopa zero out
of ten what's the difference between
that Koopa Troopa and the one that just
walks this long I think the Koopa Troopa
walks the paratrooper flies I think
that's a parable oh wait you're taking
on Bowser now yes alright let's do it
I think I don't know greetings from the
Philippines well hello
that's amazing sorry baby so we have to
do any of these two open world Oh to the
purchase screen let's see let's see we
have to collect the pink coin I think we
have to unlock everything so yeah it's
okay
did the purchase screen there but we can
do it by doing this oh yeah
it's just wait no I'm nine bucks can the
show afford this we do know we have to
earn it
we have to earn it oh so we can play
without doing that okay yeah yeah I
don't think so
wait look no because we can collect
coins I can earn it
we're gonna play these three levels for
an hour
here we go look really pick coins look
for the pink coin solder but we already
can you go back that's the thing you
can't go back so you need to know where
they are so you can your die hold on if
I can I'm gonna die and then bubble back
Paquette e [ __ ] says conan will go
bankrupt out well let's say looking at
you know you get bored this got one oh I
see it shows at the top the coins we
need there's one up there hold on hold
on you're gonna die again
maybe oh wait he died physically sighing
so that I can get bubbled back this is
called strap button it we're gonna run
out of bubbles so you can I didn't know
we can keep doing it you can't keep
doing it what does nod rod wants to know
snot rod what Conan puts his hair you
know just magic just make magic magic
your taste we got to get the coins I
think we purchased the game RJ I really
do that's cheating
we have to we have to earn it
yeah so you have 0 out of 5 points you
got one need to go up here there we go
yeah yeah there we go
see the problem was I was playing what's
that thing there's one there's one
there's long three dude you're gonna get
the ball oh [ __ ]
that's alright sorry sorry yeah just say
now bubble back cuz you got it wrong I
[Music]
mean you can argue this is kind of
cheating here we go here we go no no
this birthing it goes because you have a
certain amount of bubbles alright now I
just got to finish in 21 seconds oh the
time this is a genius game here we go
here we go here we go here we go
twelve seconds ten points so wait how
many do we need to move on to the
toboggan hotel so it's not just coming
actually Shady fridge what's up how's it
going big spokes nice dude
[Music]
rudeman how many hours we bought it this
has been going on for 17 hours I believe
I think this is the 17th hour
yeah but we have been on for 21 minutes
22 okay yeah it's going by quick
I think we have to purse it's not
letting us do it no no no no look
now if 13 out of 15 Isis we got to find
we got to find two more I'm excited I'm
excited for the challenge so as we know
it's up that's the last one I just think
it's letting us get it again Oh cutting
me after like if you already know which
one you don't have I thought it said the
last it's edited we just got a tip that
we might have to eat them all in one
shot pink masks what's the funniest
thing that's ever happened you're
probably have to have some kind of story
wait what do you do at work
oh so I wait you missed one I know but
that's I think let's see we have it
there's a good test because I think the
last one is the one we didn't have I
think I think he's right I think we got
to get him all in one shot where's the
stats
yeah we got any more one shot um let's
see
so well that's right so I I I'm the
production office coordinator at run the
production office the day-to-day in in
our office and then I also run our
intern program
so I hire all the interns and yeah I
just that's the gist of it this is a guy
you need to know keep talking
yeah so I am the yeah yeah so that's
that's it if you guys are Nick is the
best gamer of this whole stream what is
it I can't
I cannot believe Joshua shoo my favorite
person what's up that is one percent
bathroom Matt I take offense to that
100% I swear it's something different
now by the way don't worry about it he
does costume changes even when he's not
on camera
[Laughter]
what's a blaze costume change
are you unlocking the game right now see
lays blessing thank you sir
thanks dude later let's get back to you
being the best at this game back we
couldn't even beat level 1 of Mario oh
my god this is Bowser's Castle are we
ready for this is the chat ready for
this
can i play Bowser's yeah you need to do
this you need a safe is on all right
let's do it RJ we trust all right here
we go
bear ski wants to know is this the sixth
shirt change for bleh this is number six
oh gosh my god where are they the exact
same shorts yeah that's awesome
bleh needs his own clothing line you
guys oh I wouldn't wear it I would never
but I feel like someone a lot of people
want to know where Jordan is Jordan -
what is he doing at five he's definitely
a week has he been on this or no no he's
not coming on that far as I was not
gonna but he's definitely awake that guy
has a I see he has a strict morning
we've seen everything oh is that true I
would just imagine yeah I just think
he's ill he's up in 1,000 pounds here we
go here we go this reminds me of the
Bowser from
[Music]
well apparently I don't know how to play
here we go here we go what I'm sorry
guys Madeleine Sims I would wear blame
arch for sure listen who wouldn't all
right Alan what up we're gonna beat this
right now yeah you're gonna beat it well
this is just the first world but would
be a lot it could be a lot to go
[Music]
well I better go down there I bet
there's a boy down there yep any way I
can do that Oh
come on man
see they said a good thing about me and
my gaming skills they've really got to
your head oh my god they really got to
your head
Wow zero deaths somebody said well not
anymore
sorry I let you guys down
I'm sorry too got it
didn't get it the first time
[Music]
here we go
you got this
[Music]
did shouts all the people running this
thing we've been here 17 yeah yeah good
call crazy you know this kind of reminds
me of his uh then get ready for a
horrible story but uh did related yeah
get ready for a horrible school yeah
Raja says this reminds me of when I was
when I was in college I did a play once
I was in a musical which is weird and
the local news came at like 5:00 a.m.
and they were like you have to give to
sing a song for Fido you have to get a
man come here everybody shield your eyes
for one second you have to just make it
quick just do a quick casual walk
through in that this is good I feel the
vault there you go oh my god it's
blinding that's gross
we don't want to lose the viewers I just
want everyone to see do you wear that we
needed out we needed that yes I did god
how do i oh i see it okay
I thought I was I was trying to jump on
his head I gotta get this hammer there's
an audible know from somebody back there
it's not gonna win the cruise sir yeah
yeah all right let's see the speed it'd
be easy no pressure but Oh blaze
adorable that is fact yeah it's a strong
and getting this point now enough is
enough getting this money embarrass he
said this looks like a grandma's couch
it's a pretty stylish couch or you wish
style a stylish grandmother it's pretty
comfortable also
I'm feeling good wicked something could
be comment on my performance right now
so far this is big this is strong this
is a strong run it's something strong
you just have to be Bowser
which by the way the first bouncer
imagine how much harder here we going to
get here we go alright so I think you
gotta wait now
oh [ __ ] oh you have to go under him
maybe oh oh oh you got lucky
you've got suppose I had the mushroom
that's called luck I'm not gonna give
you that one who he turned into a little
of mushroom guy all the little guys are
being you jump on and they squish
goombas really yeah big smokes confirmed
Goomba yep
Goomba okay what do you think you guys
here's something I think everyone wants
to know in the chat what is your
favorite video game of all time one game
actually know the answer this can one
way you do I think I'm one my feet my
favorite video game of all time that's a
great question I wanna hear what you
guys is favorite video game favorite
video game of all time might be it might
be the Ocarina of Time okay alright
Zelda Ocarina of Time alright that's
actually not what I was thinking for you
what were you thinking I knew that is
Mario Kart I was gonna say Mario Kart 64
freedom which is also good you can't go
wrong you know those games so Star Fox
has always been like one of my favorite
yeah yes I always wanted to be a pilot
and that kind of lets me live that out
as a fox man Star Fox is the most
realistic lighting for the gala the most
realistic flight simulator there is RJ
have you not played any of the Indiana
Jones games no someone clearly knows
that I love in the energy wases and I
did not know that that was
that is my whole life by the way
Indiana Jones I had no idea
good morning r.j. and jean jacket guy
jacket guy that is his name he goes by
Nick I'll take me what his legal name is
jean jacket if there's an Indiana Jones
game that anyone can recommend hook me
up because I have never heard of one I
think I've seen a Lego one maybe I don't
know that did exist this n on a fate of
Atlantis was that on like PC oh I feel
like there was a great one on Sega
Genesis really I think so and it kind of
used it was like emissions from all the
three movies so it wasn't just one of
the movies it was like I can't get that
coin
[Music]
man I haven't been paying attention at
all where are we here we're in the
ghostly house okay
ghost the ghost house by the way it was
my least favorite level Mario Kart team
really yeah it was not easy to fall see
I like to go sell something what are you
trying to have to be into that green
door oh this is actually gonna be okay
yeah
finally a little challenge for me
honestly I don't quite know how to do
the hairy guy wait no that's a good idea
I wanna go through here
oh I'm down there I actually don't know
the answer I don't know chant a little
help guys what do we do we don't know
what to do I know that I need to want to
run out of time for sure twelve seconds
or die James Packer don't worry Aaron
will be back I assume he needs a break
he needs to probably napping somewhere
yeah let the man have a break Ellery oh
gosh planning out his next t-shirt at
the moment I finally created out with
five seconds left to go
whoo someone said their favorite
videogame Dakota Harrison said Tekken
you're liking I do remember tucking yeah
technicans wasn't there like 10 Tekken
seconds good my favorite video game of
all time
Latasha says this reminds I think this
reminds her of Sonic interesting it was
a great game Sonic was a great game but
Mario and Sonic are truly mortal enemies
yeah they're like rivals right maybe
yeah maybe not enemies but they're
rivals for sure wait big smoke says
contra contra so RJ and I have been
trying to beat contra 3 for the Super
Nintendo and by saying we're trying to
beat it like we are trying to beat it
but we can't get past the second level
no we're bad at that game personal
contra 3 is bum rates Danny Kali Racing
was a good one - who did he come racing
was great you could fly guys
Owen Parker says Tony Hawk pro skater
for I don't remember which one was which
but I like the Tony Hawk games Sonico
six Asian deuces that is a terrible
terrible game Sonic 2006 is a bad game
why it's bad it's a good Tori ously bad
google sonic oh six and it's really hate
it it's a terrible turn Nick lavich says
did you try the new Zelda breath of the
while I did play that and I loved it
it's great I beat it
I got everything it's a great great game
I love that I'm so sorry you guys have
to watch this right now
a horrible showing World of Warcraft is
a way of life not a game I don't play it
but I've heard that it can be a life
consuming night 47 seconds left to
figure out this is like a puzzle I don't
really know what I'm supposed to this
yet you have this is this is this is
dimple you have to go up I'll point to
it on then do and try
I've got ramen yeah sonic boom you got a
big Sonic fan in the chat okay so you
have to get through all the doors et for
the Atari is obviously the best game
ever you never played Atari really yeah
gamer tread helped them into this I saw
it leave your body like give nothing
come on you have to play a little credit
had it's gone
[Music]
me I'm so sorry so on this day on this
jump on that that jump yeah you want to
get like a Peter and then yeah yeah oh
you already did that actually you
already did the hardest part I can't do
anything after that I'll just get on
that no shady fridge you guys should do
it retro stream playing all games on
their original consoles that'd be great
maybe cool yeah oh yeah which store you
think I think you have to clear out all
the doors in order to move
[Music]
[Music]
come on see no no you just have to get
the right door oh there you go nice
bring back the Gamecube well and partner
says game kid was great
oh it's under an hour sorry only took me
oh it's the dope Nick lavich says I
think it's the door that doesn't wiggle
okay good tip oh there's a good tip
thank you thank you thank you here we go
here we go here we go there we go
big smokes Nick do you remember the
intern remote you are on I do remember
that god that was a while ago but I do
remember that yeah it was great what
happened in that is when that's the
infamous sugar packets in turn that's
that's uh organizing the famous the
people people really people writing
songs about her yeah I didn't write the
whole thing was Conan ambush the interns
and you know hilarity ensued
[Music]
I don't know that I've put I think this
is the level I have not seen ever so
this is all new territory for me
this is cool Nick since my name is Nick
can you be Nick - sure sure I'll be Nick
- Nick - it's better than jean jacket
guy no I did we give our jasa props for
improvement that we're seeing already
this is go RJ go bear ski says all right
thanks fair ski guys it's Wednesday I'm
sure you've already gone over that oh no
I thought I could jump on these guys oh
sorry how many hours left
well let's see we're at it's 5:40 we're
going in till noon help me with the map
it's way too early six I'm gonna let you
do the math six and a half hour oh is oh
I see there we go look at that I thought
I was I thought it was a digital oh yes
24-hour original Nintendo stream that
would be great
hello from the UK Jakob Bradley hey man
how's it going the UK you know I
recently in a trivia a trivia match got
got the question wrong because I said
that Scotland was a country yeah I felt
I felt you know what I think I would
have done the same thing I wasn't really
in the moment I was really thinking
about the United Kingdom as his dump
Michael Allen says congrats on being
good at the baby game from babies babies
I would love to see a baby play this
game I would too I mean that would be
fun you know what let's bring a baby
well you should say that we have babies
on hand do you what happen Robert James
Monday says it's 8:30 where he's at in
Florida cool shout out to Florida big
shout out to Florida here yeah yeah
Florida
sergeant we don't need to know about
this level okay so you jump on these
little things that stop you from going
pain these aren't walls so you can't
jump off as you just found out just one
that I'll see you gotta watch out for
the missiles bullet bills are the name
you know the name bullet bills no idea
that oh my gosh ray O'Brien says I
remember that trivia where I got a
scholar rock rocky he was Wow Cyndi West
is in Florida too
maybe you guys are new to each other
this is love bjurman Florida I have been
to Florida yes I've been to Tampa Bay
that's the bother I have to have been to
the stadium Tropicana Field my parents
used to go to Fort Lauderdale
so then the Fort Lauderdale a couple
times because my grandparents lived
there that's the end of that story
it's nothing else good give it up for
our guest grandparent yeah there you go
next one for you excited
sided you got 737 out of 30 Koopas 4 out
of 60 bullet bills 2 out of 5
pink coins so that's not great
2 out of 5 is not nothing but we're on
the 3rd to let you know we're on the 3rd
level making progress of world to
Zachary's wants to know have y'all been
to Texas have y'all been to Texas oh
yeah yeah we have been SEC I was
actually lived in Texas for a short
amount of time
yeah I did and then we also did the show
from Texas in Dallas a few years ago at
the Majestic Theatre in Dallas Texas the
new limit I lived in Waco Texas a short
amount of time yeah very young but yes
it didn't have you seen that show wake
up I have seen great it was actually be
singularity wants to know is it talk to
Taco Tuesday or casual denim Friday ooh
good question good question I don't know
the answer to this is right in the
middle
there's Taco Tuesday when the stream
started that's true now what it's not
Friday close to schedule one but I'm
gonna tell you something I've never worn
this shirt on a Tuesday ever my whole
life on purpose
because I don't I don't think you should
I'm rocking this rocket we appreciate
this music for a second this beef is
crazy this is like really really get
somebody can we get a CD for Nick I need
I need this whole video scarce on
Spotify oh I just rocked that level I
think I think you are now no no it's
your turn
we're at the we're at the castle I think
oh but I didn't kill any of those what
are those five I have no idea actually
don't know what those are calling back
they look like a bad blue bat does any
of the blue bats in Mario at home
Stephanie Townsend's it is Wacky
Wednesday yes it is yeah where does it
blue background guys with a swoop we're
just been told they're called the swoops
okay I like that
here we go this is Oh an airship
[Music]
guys this is my level I love any kind of
ship I'll have any tradition here we go
there we go
patella grasses piece I believe it was
her from Zelda I wouldn't have made it
past any of that without a star get that
do you want I'm in a group group here we
go I don't who's this guy
Cooper's teenage son this is he looks
angry do I jump on him let me jump right
on him
got them again how is that one easier
than the first Bowser I just think
you're getting better I think it's what
it is it's like it's not getting harder
you're just getting better we're getting
easier I think your chest with the
ticket the caddy kick peck peck II what
you fake wants to know have you met a
celebrity guests on the show RJ have you
met anyone that stuck out or I don't
know I guess I'm asked I'm adding
questions to her question but let's see
let's see
bees music one one three hey what's up
[Music]
that's it man I'm trying to think of a
good celeb good celeb encounter is it
Jordan
George yes Jordan the vessel I met
Jordan once and in the kitchen I was
getting a pop tart and he looked at me
all right here we go okay okay yeah here
world-- 3-row but every let's keep going
what's fresh decay ass is jordyn hot
what are your thoughts Nick I mean I
think it's pretty obvious right someone
asks what's the twitch it's arts which
name team cocoa Team Coco it's easy easy
to remember
yes we're on twitch YouTube Facebook and
Facebook
it's what YouTube and Facebook awesome
not my best stuff guys someone else is
asking the similarity asking if you look
I think they're talking about you
looking like Ben Affleck I've never
heard that one before I've seen Ben
Affleck on your three times since we've
sat down is that the glass does he wear
glasses I don't know I have not heard
that one before I'll take it I guess I
mean he played Batman and cool with that
right like if I could be Batman Ben
Affleck wears a lot of jean jackets oh
is that what it is Oh
send us ask Nick do you have any gamer
tats that's a good question I've
wondered that do you have any gamer
tattoos I don't have her ink I don't
have any gamer egg I do like I like
tattoos I think tattoos are cool tell me
you don't have a big Princess Peach all
down your back I don't I don't but I do
like I think daddy's rich never could
decide what I would want on me forever
but maybe it's princess is there
anything anything is there any way you
would get a tattoo yeah I mean yeah I
would get what I would get a tattoo I
would get a tattoo I just don't know
like what what will we get how would you
get to the
point and getting it tattooed that's the
thing I don't know what needs to happen
in my life for me to to tap myself
though like it you know if something
needs to happen that would be like I
need to put this on like prison okay or
go into space I've always said that if I
ever went to space I would get that
would you would you get space like the
name of my not here but like the name of
my spaceship okay that I flew space it's
assuming that I'm piloting the spaceship
all right let's see maybe if I like
sailed around the world I'd hit that
tattooed but again what would its age
the [ __ ] in the world I just need some
kind of mode of transportation tattooed
on oh I like these things really good
stuff fresh decay would say get said I
would get an Alex Kidd in miracle world
being tattooed nice obscure callback to
an old game I don't know what that is
that I don't know Alex Kidd is an old
game I believe there's on the Sega
Master System which was like before the
Sega Genesis I mean remember when
someone said that you were a better
gamer than Kramer that made my morning
probably my whole day the only thing
that would make it better is if I knew
Kramer was watching right now oh he is
he might be uh you might get up you
might be up now he's watching yellow
lemon lb you guys have a favorite ps4 or
Xbox one game for me I prop I play a lot
of MLB - oh I'm a big baseball fan so I
so probably that have you put anything
on the isolate baseball outside
no I had no I haven't he's more of an
outdoors guy yeah no yeah so yeah what
is the name of this game this is Mari
Super Mario run or just Mario run Super
Mario wait we have we've we've talking
points here we do realize this okay this
could have been saying that's right
where is Kramer traffic wants to know I
don't know he's in his cave Kramer does
live in a cave all right you're up this
level looks fun though I can see - uh -
what big bullets passing each other
big boy these called the same we've been
over this RJ what do they call missile
Mike's missile Mike what are they called
Bob bullet Bob's bullet Bob's really
yeah bullet fires all right bear ski
couldn't sleep right now even missile
Mike's a new name confirm I love it good
listen Mike yeah get Nintendo on the
line we're changing as missile Mike's do
I write the next Mario game right now do
people write the games I don't know how
much of a story I mean I get you could
write it some ways right now yeah sure
bullet Brad somebody said I like that
name to LeBron cannon bullet Bill's
cannon cannon Connors yeah
someone said nothing rgeous no very true
B's music one with three RJ are you
single
nope dates I'm getting like weirdly
slap-happy maybe it's actually a yogi
it's not even five anymore it's almost
6:00 yeah chugging through oh yeah here
we go
Nick if you got married today with the
music at your wedding be the Mario theme
it would be that but it would be the
underground the dinner lumen in it then
another one I want that one that's it
all right
like the impending doom what's keep it
moving keep moving keep moving
got caught up thinking about my dream
wedding super moment so what's up with
that background oh gosh I don't even
noticed our background it's a bunch of
coins I did just look back to see if it
was my eyes it's not I'm sure this is a
green screen there are not coins right
back there coins that's awesome
bees music I've been watching the stream
still too long well what's too long it
sounds like how long we've been watching
bees music first of all too long he's
not a thing when it comes to this you
guys should be Keibler keep watching
just forever you know when this is over
go back and watch it again in 24 hours
yeah all 24 hours in one sitting
that's the best way to take all this in
is in one yeah and unfortunately like I
and I'm sure people everyone's busy they
have to turn in and out I understand
your lies but you're not getting the
full thing yes 24 hours straight is the
only way to do this so after you see
this little segment you're tuning in
right now you want to go back and watch
this whole thing from start to finish
just like you would a game of throne
I'm Breaking Bad
yeah did you just compare the 24 hour
stream of that thing Breaking Bad I mean
listen I agreed this has been great
saying Bobby asks why Mario run
why not Mario run Mario I think we can
all agree is the greatest video game
character of all time
I think there's no argument there right
I think and I'm not saying it's always
the best game but like he's the guy he's
the face of video yeah okay so that's
why Mario run I mean get up you don't do
a 24 hour gaming stream and not show
Mario at some point I think is I think
everybody understands that these music
has been watching since 3:00 last night
the intera and it is now 1453 Wow here's
another question you know what 1453 is
and yes it is 253 in it no close wait no
wait 12 is 12
sure and 13 is 1 and I said oh 2 we're
listen I thought you said 1-3 I don't
know I said - I wasn't listening
my bad at math or you bad at listening I
think I said to both someone says
pac-man is better than Mario oh hey
thoughts yeah I don't know if I agree
with it I don't know who that I like
pac-man but like who's you know better I
just start a war and I look at this this
pac-man in Mario or I think he did I
think he did
all right let's keep oh we run the next
castle hook me up
me all right boots guys 5 5 58 something
happening in two minutes
Oh
oh never mind good time good time clock
I'm looking after him
wait Nate Dogg just said do you guys
like gladiator movies now you have a
comment about this yes I do
I'm never going to admit this to the
chapel guy I've been trying to get jean
jacket guy to watch it's gonna stick if
you keep calling I have been trying to
get you to watch the movie Gladiator
with Russell Crowe I've never got around
to it I don't need light on the why two
years maybe and you won't do it why I
just I tell them who you mean no no no
I'm not gonna say I just wow I just I
just know I don't know you've never drew
me in I know I was never that interested
in it but I'll see it I've seen just
about everything I don't I don't know
why I haven't seen that I will see it
one day you have my copy this is a hard
one okay one more time of course
all right you've had my copy of
gladiator for why do you hit a great
score problem while I'm gonna watch it
I'm gonna watch the chat wants me to
watch it I'm gonna watch glad watching
the chat wants you to do it you'll do it
and I'm your pal RJ once you do it
speaking up you're getting a lot of Adam
Sandler people think you can really
we're gonna see it a little bit hey you
have to go sorry run easy eric says
scuffed Ben Affleck I think they're
talking about you again
scuffed me I think they're talking about
like scuffed seems like a negative word
this heels like a Ben Affleck I think
Ben Affleck art is I don't know what
scuffed means I guess I don't to say
that Ben Affleck is already scuffed
without knowing what scuffed means but
in my head it means like chiseled chin
how can you see a Walmart Ben Affleck
I'll take that I'll take that like I was
that better I don't think it's better
but you know I'll take any and get
Joanne hello from Germany hey how's it
going let's see
RJ's write about gladiator all right
well listen yeah party's right I'll
watch the things going keep going well
no we were the whole screen right yeah
oh honey he doesn't even see the game
yeah oh wait wait is RJ the one who had
the gigolos muggy yes that is RJ he had
someone as a gigolo hug that's true it
was that someone just said I look like
the son of Tony Hawk it's weird to the
Amazon
guys I have an announcement Tony Hawk
Marge a hawk yes I stole sona's gigolo
mug while you was so not on the stream
yes your Spurs her and David did it
first
oh nice early it was very early
yesterday awesome um you stole some
asthma again it's you
our Jayhawk I love it Oh God our Jayhawk
so we all Riley is I think that's is
that really the same Riley from some
angles RJ looks like Nicolas Cage that's
a good one too
the yellow lemon Australia what's up
wait as Nicolas Cage and Ben Affleck
ever been in a movie together I don't
think so I don't think so hmm not that I
can they have now
mmm-hmm decades on route over called him
leakage
Jeff Woodruff asks how much of the Pixar
movie was based on Coco's life
oh the Coco Co the movie yeah I think
it's it's a biography right isn't it
yeah I think it's a whole biopic of
Conan I'm excited that you look like Ben
Affleck by the way it makes me makes me
happy
I love Good Will Hunting everyone all
back excellent change your shorts place
standing next to us who changed his
shorts all right it's 6:00 a.m. 6:00
with Conan hey Conan take it away
Conan okay 6:00 a.m. I know you've all
been waiting for this
there's the Andy doll let's see who it
is producer Jeff Ross Jeff Ross there he
is smiling I don't recognize him he
never smiles he's always like this but
let's go come on this is the guy that
stands behind the podium and makes the
show run he also likes soup and there he
is dressed for his execution I don't
know what's going on in this but anyway
that is Jeff Ross and that is the next
hole but you want to know what you don't
find out till 7:00
Stew's the next dog place your bets
Vegas oddsmakers are going nuts this has
become a huge trend on the Internet this
is huge
who's the next Russian doll we'll find
out soon thanks Conan thanks great what
a guy
great to hear from him guys we're we're
currently cycling through the stream so
if you lose contact you can jump over to
YouTube or twitch for facebook so
apologies for any kind of weird thing
but in order to keep it going for 24
hours we got to cycle through so yeah
we're changing games new game changing
to new game it is plants vs. zombies - I
have no idea how to play this one so
we're gonna learn